welcome everybody to the i'm not a gm speed
chess championship i'm grand master robert hess
alongside me the one and only grandmaster mon
hamilton amman you had the call for the first
match this is just our second how you feeling
about the prime time matchup between danny
wrench and lawrence trent well first of all hello
robert hello everybody it's good to be back for
the uh as you said the second match here i think
lawrence against danny is is a lot of people's
closest matchup in in the first round i want
to say because uh you know everyone knows about
lawrence danny and you know they've been going
back and forth on twitter a little bit as well so
feels like there's a little bit of heat behind
this match but i honestly had this match up as
one of the closest to expect from round one robert
absolutely and they are the 710 matchup if i'm not
mistaken but before we continue talking to players
let's remind everyone of the format because this
is a single elimination knockout they will have 75
minutes of the longer time which will five minute
plus one second increment followed by 45 minutes
of three plus one and finally 25 minutes of bullet
in one plus one of course the winner making it
to the quarter finals and the prizes not bad eh
amman seems like pretty good paydays for these
players who really it's pride at stake but also
some prizes yeah i mean i i i was thinking about
maybe just putting my gm title on hold and seeing
if i could sneak in this tournament uh because
those prizes don't look half bad robert well if
only this tournament had begun a few years earlier
because you've cemented that gm title for a while
now but let's look at the bracket because you
mentioned this one as being the toss-up that
everyone would be a bit conflicted about and when
i look from top to bottom here we know that greg
shahadi has made his way into the quarterfinals
what other matchups catch your eye here
well um first of all the tournament has changed
a little bit from the first edition which is
that it's not only ims competing in this event we
have a lot of other streamers personalities and
and a lot of familiar names for for a lot
of the twitch viewers here i think a very
underrated matchup which will be insanely close
is actually right underneath that greg match-up
tiny assassinative against uh kostya kavitsky so
i think that match is going to be very very close
and we also have eric rosen against sagar shaw
and to be quite honest i don't know what to expect
from cigar it's not someone that i've seen play in
this format too much and i think that that might
be uh just kind of a dark horse matchup to look
out for for sure because we don't know the bullet
skills in particular you know all these players
are very strong but if they're not well practiced
online that could be a problem and one matchup
that i'm really looking forward to is the one
beneath this one with lars oscar howe could take
out alina kashinskaya of course alina under seated
at number 14 considering she made her way to the
finals last year and she's looking not just to
repeat that but even win this whole thing yeah no
that that is a criminally underseated i would say
alina is very very dangerous in every format which
is what she demonstrated in the first edition
for sure and well you know while we have been
talking about some other matchups today we do have
danny against lauren so i'm pretty pumped for
this one it's danny getting ready playing a bit
of bullet in fact winning this bullet game that
i have on my computer in front of me and lawrence
was playing bullet himself so you think they're
a little bit nervous here i i think that they
they both seem to have the same idea that neither
guy wants to weigh into this match a little light
they're looking to get the highest rating possible
even right up to the start of the game clock to
intimidate the the opponent and even the big boss
had to have that fair play cam going on where
they're on screen right of course in front
of them so we can see their faces but also
their surroundings to ensure that they are
competing fairly we know that they are but
it's just taking those precautionary measures
just to uphold fair play and well the play
hopefully is a bit better than fair i think
that we would like to see these players
give their best because lawrence and danny they're
not going to hold any punches as you mentioned
them on on twitter they've been going at it so
what do you think we'll see over the board itself
well i think one of the interesting things about
lawrence as a competitor is that i find him to be
a very um almost like a like a he plays chess
like he plays poker maybe he's very emotional
and driven by his emotions so if he has a good
game he's going to ride that momentum into the
next game whereas if he has a bad game it might
affect his next game in a negative way more than
it might affect other players so you know you live
by the sword dive by the sword but i think that's
one of the things that really defines lawrence as
a player that if he gets on a roll if he's feeling
himself he's a showman and uh we could really see
you know in any section if he wins one two games
in a row he's really going to stick it to danny so
i think that that the emotional side of things is
really going to come into play as for the bullet
as you mentioned we saw both of these guys warming
up with bullets so maybe maybe it speaks to the
fact that that could be the defining segment of
this match yeah i like what you said there about
the emotions because speaking of emotions danny
sometimes gets a little too attached to certain
openings as you know full well from beating me
and danny you and eric teamed up from the chess
broad chess com showdown where you all won but
sometimes he gets a little too attached to
certain openings and certain ideas so i know
that he loves a good queen sacrifice sometimes
it's an inopportune moment and he'll need to
reign that in because at his best danny can beat
anybody in this field and i i really do believe
that this match is a toss-up i would actually give
a slight nod to danny as objectively as i possibly
can be i think that he's a little bit stronger
a little bit faster than lawrence's these days
yeah yeah and i i think one of the important
characteristics that you do not want to have in
a match like this is actually stubbornness uh when
when you're playing an opening and it's not going
your way especially when you get down to the
bullet if you're playing something in five minute
it's not working three minutes not working it's
definitely not going to work in bullet it's
going to get worse as the time gets lower so you
won't be able to adapt have a few options ready
that hey if something's not working out you know
you can play something else because i think the
the stubbornness of certain players being as
you said attached to a certain opening too much
is actually their detriment i completely agree and
while we do have what will be a promising match
ahead of us today i want to remind everybody
that we do have more action in the i'm not a
gm speeches championship international master levy
rosman better known as gotham chess throughout the
twitch sphere taking on james canty the third
that is an im versus nm national master match
up and i'm on just to do a quick little preview of
that of course on paper levy is the heavy favorite
james very popular commentator and streamer
in his own right what are his chances like
yeah well obviously in this uh this tournament
because it's changed a little bit and not everyone
is in i am uh you're gonna have mismatches like uh
let's say the match that i previously commentated
between alexandra and greg shahadi of course greg
the heavy favorite on paper going into that match
and that's why they had a handicap in place to
to make that more fair now in this matchup i
don't think any handicap is necessary for an
entertaining match robert but i do think that
if cantee is gonna have his chances um i think
it probably will need to come uh as strange as
it sounds in the blitz portions we we know levy
to be just quite quite dangerous in bullet and
i don't see james stacking up to him in the
bullet portion so strange as it sounds i think his
chances are actually in the blitz robert yeah one
of the things i like most about james is that his
username is gm canty and he's striving to become
the best title in chess and i was looking up his
ratings on chess.com his blitz rating in the 2500s
his bullet rating actually in the 2600s but as you
said levy he's been known to play a great bullet
game or two his ratings are through the roof
and that's going to be a tough matchup for
james but before we even get to that matchup
we will have the arena king season six starting
tomorrow and i'm on you gonna take part in this
yeah this is exciting like uh it's nice to have
arena kings back i think there is gonna be more
hype than ever for this season because there's
more people streaming than ever for this season
and that's you know one of the requirements to
to win prizes in arena kings is you have to be
streaming and we know how many people have picked
up streaming lately and how many people blown up
uh in the streaming sphere so um it's gonna
be pretty exciting i know that eric and i are
probably gonna swap in uh swap out for different
uh different editions of uh arena kings but
i'll definitely get some uh get some goes in
i think whoever is doing better in the season
will let them ride it out that makes sense well i
look forward to seeing you not just commentating
alongside you but against you in the arena kings
i definitely plan on taking part as well and amman
you know it's about that time huh we have
just a couple minutes before the games begin
the players settling in there looks like lawrence
is laughing about something seems typical for him
i don't know i mean the five minute portion it's
a long segment there with 75 total minutes they
do get a break about halfway through the players
get a few minutes to relax but i really feel like
with two players who are quite emotional in
nature that whoever gets out to the hot start
that could be the person who leads from start to
finish yeah as strange as it sounds even the guy
who wins game one is uh is gonna be at that um
you know emotional advantage that you're gonna
really be feeling uh feeling good um i think
that early on we're gonna get that taste of
what i mentioned about stubbornness you know
if if there's an opening disaster in game one
are we going to see that correct it for the second
time that that these guys play white and black
the exact same colors or uh are we gonna see maybe
just a repeat of a bad opening for one of these
players so i think it's really important early on
to see how the opening phase goes for both players
and whether or not either of these players needs
to adapt early on and i think stylistically the
way these two players clash will be interesting
because danny from the white side he's an e4
player and when people play e5 he often plays
the scotch line which as you know from experience
doesn't always end well for him but uh lawrence is
more of a sicilian player so that's going to allow
for more tactical battles and i think that's to
both sides benefit they both love aggressive play
yeah and that that that just
means that we're danny has got his
mug up to the up to the camera i don't know
what that was that lawrence on that mug or
danny by the way has got like some sort of like
bike courier wristband on looks like he's about
to deliver me like pizza or something that or he's
about to do some crossfit while playing chess so
uh i think that while they're messing around
they're gonna stop very soon because the game
should start any second now yeah and we're being
told that was actually ryan gosling on the mug
so that's like the weirdest thing
i could have guessed would be on
that mug but you also gave the biggest
compliment to lauren's trend of his life
just thought that lawrence's face was ryan
gosling's face and who could be upset with that
compliment yeah i i don't know i i gave lawrence
ryan gosling when he looks a lot more like slicker
from the uk as well that is
very funny and i see the game
is just starting here danny with e4 oh no i quit
oh man robert this is this is not the the best
start for you let's see oh well i think that this
is more of what is okay what is this variation
by lawrence because he put his knight on c6
which as we know in the french you often want
to play c5 instead he's just going for tricks
yeah this looks like um i don't know how to how
to describe it but it looks like one of those
lines you might you might hustle a few games
in the park with um this line definitely looks
like something lawrence has prepared and is
sort of happy to to get against danny here
yeah and i will say that right now danny is left
with a tough decision which is why he hasn't moved
whether to take that pawn on bassan he takes f6
or you could have played a move ago or to leave it
he decides to leave it and say to lawrence i'm not
afraid of what looks like a good central control
for you because i'm able to counter later in the
game maybe with a c4 idea or to move this knight
away from f3 and try to play f3 with a pawn but
i actually i don't mind black's position somehow
yeah i mean the the nice thing about black's
position is you kind of have these knight a5
ideas and if you could ever trade light squared
bishops off i mean you're just laughing uh if
you have lawrence's position for sure and that
bishop one d3 will need to remain there as amman's
pointing out that knight would love to go a5 to c4
and potentially it does that even with the bishop
still on d3 because that dark square bishop which
we often think of as an advantage it's not doing
much of anything and doesn't have any targets to
apply pressure on yeah and if you go for some plan
like 91 f3 i mean black doesn't really care sure
he takes the bishop on d2 but the knight on e1 is
not going to be in a great position after you play
f3 and take away its square of return to the game
meanwhile black has a couple moves in between
he's got the knight a5 plan and maybe try to
trade light square bishops so i really don't
mind lawrence's position right out of the gate
and let's not forget about the time advantage
robert as danny is he's kind of in a new position
he really is and you know if as i reflect already
it's only move ten but as i think back of the
opening maybe taking on passant was better because
white would have had free flow with the pieces
although so would black's pieces right because
if had the pawn go away from the f file and the
e5 pawn black has the semi-open file things of
that nature so i think that danny is reflecting
that himself while trying to continue this game
and that is dangerous territory because as we
both know from experience when you're playing
a game but reflecting on the past moves you're
distracting yourself from being as objective
as possible about the current situation yeah
that's a good point you brought that up before
the match that that danny sometimes you know
hold on holds on to thoughts for for too long and
really just needs to say okay the decision's done
let's continue if he wants to change that decision
well that's why he can repeat this opening
and there's an easy uh way to to deviate from
this game in case he wants to repeat this line
for sure and he is down quite a lot in the clock
lauren this is a slow paced game right now robert
yeah and well it's hard because you start with
five minutes and most of us when we play blitz
we're like three minutes you and i when we're
going at it three minutes yes so then you think oh
i'm in a comfort zone where i have a couple more
minutes to spend and then you start spending it
too early and your opponent builds up a big lead
it is a two-minute time advantage for lawrence
and i kind of like his position right now so yeah
not a good start for danny no i wouldn't say so
right now danny is kind of uh in the middle of
two plans he wishes maybe his bishop was on e1
so that the knight didn't have anything to capture
and f3 might look towards kicking that knight out
for real but right now after f3 i mean lord's
just going to take that bishop on d2 queen takes
and maybe he's going to go either bishop d7
or b6 and just get that light square bishop
i'm with you and that d3 square is one that white
would like to share with the bishop and the knight
because black's idea is to play c5 but if white's
knight were on d3 then you take away that option
or at least make it more difficult to play and
he plays bishop e2 perhaps for this purpose but
i don't know black can just play c5 here and even
then it's like you're getting exactly what you
want out of a french yeah absolutely no this looks
and also the other thing is if you go b6 and white
ever goes knight d3 it might be nice in some cases
to play bishop a6 i can't tell just so you always
have that that trade in your back pocket wow and
lawrence wants more he's saying i'm pushing my
pawns forward because knight d3 comes at the tempo
on that f4 pawn but he might just play g5 and
one of these positions amman you can tell me it
feels like it's too risky in my opinion but then
sometimes it's justified for black yeah i i think
that the way i would view it is that the position
looked honestly good enough that i wouldn't bother
going for this but it's not to say that this is
not a very valid way to play so it's just more in
lawrence's style and you know for that reason i i
think it's probably better that that he he plays
this way it's he's as you said an aggressive
attacking player he he's got that f pawn up there
he wants to maybe have the queen join the party
on h4 or on g5 and you know if he ever gets that
queen g5 sort of knight h4 with f3 ideas uh if
they start kicking around there this could be very
good but on the other hand danny gets to execute
the one plan that i mentioned earlier bishop e1
and now f3 for white is something to think about
it's funny because both of our plans somehow
happen the bishop went to e1 the knight went
to d3 and the bishop went to e2 so both of our
plans have come to fruition here and i like
white's position because his pawn f4 look at this
he's already targeting it he can put more pressure
with queen to c1 if he wants but i wouldn't just
focus all my energy there because black is going
to play queen g5 or queen h4 as you mentioned so
playing queen c1 feels like so it's one trick i'm
going after four pawn easy defend instead danny
brings his knight around is that knight coming to
h3 i i think he just wanted the bishop on d3 and
um the interesting thing about this position is
i feel like if it gets into a maneuvering game
that i sort of prefer white i think that white's
pieces have more room to improve in this position
like kind of higher ceilings they honestly
it's been bishop bishop knight that have been
dancing around about five squares for the last
seven moves so uh i think danny's pieces can only
get better and i think one way to improve your
pieces is to take this pawn on c5 which may seem
counterintuitive because the e5 pawn drops but
when you start removing pawns from the position
you free up the remaining squares and here
i think that lawrence can play c4 to trap
that bishop to force it to capture an f5
and as you were saying white's pieces can improve
but now i'm not really seeing exactly how and that
cemented double pawns in the c file those in the
long run are not going to be favorable pawns for
yeah and i also was thinking about ctag's d4 just
because if danny would have to trade on f5 there
then you sort of get that open c file and and
in this position at least i don't think danny
is too unhappy in the sense that there's no open
c file there's no targets for for black he's got
this a pawn to look at danny's got the f4 pawn it
looks fairly balanced here and as we know we have
opposite bishops which does speak to a bit more of
a balanced game but perhaps a few more king side
opportunities here for lawrence yeah and one of
the things about these opposite colored bishops
is if white plays a5 black can play b5 and keep
that queen side closed thanks to this bishop on d7
white does not have a piece that can go attack
a light square on the queen side so i think that
lawrence is relying on that danny's just saying
what what do i have to do here i don't really need
to move right my position is very solid he doesn't
need to move but he has less time so in fact he
does need to move that's the issue is when you've
when you've sort of got these closed positions or
there's not much going on time like the the
fact that you're up on time becomes so much
more important that's very true and i meant that
more so in a positional point of view but you're
right to look at the clock because danny is down
a minute but what is black's idea i'm not quite
sure what is white's idea i'm also not sure i
see both sides sort of shuffling around and then
that's where the time travel really makes its mark
because look danny put that on a5 and on a6 but in
the long run that pawn could be a target and it's
on a light square so black can try to attack it
so i think lawrence wants to put his rook on f8
which frees up either his queen or his other rook
and then maybe rook h5 takes h3 is definitely
a sacrifice that i'm looking at immediately
knight h4 and queen g6 happens and i think danny
is really at risk right now of just getting mated
like just getting obliterated on the king's side
if he goes for something like queen c5 or queen d6
i can see rook f8 and like bishop e8 happening and
as we see rook h5 i think this could get really
scary for danny here although cool line is queen's
things if rook b6 maybe you could sack your queen
on b6 and push that a pawn forward i haven't
calculated it at all but that is a thematic queen
sack to have a free pawn to promote and so that's
why lauren says i don't want to deal with any of
that let me bring my rook to f8 and now i'm with
you on this is looking very easy for block to play
yeah and as soon as that bishop gets defended on
d7 queen g6 hits c2 which is strangely enough it's
actually a very important pawn um and and
even just like okay knight g4 played but i
think we're going to see some kind of breakthrough
eventually like rook g5 pawn h5 and i'm not really
sure how danny intends to meet that it seems very
straightforward yeah i have no idea i have no idea
because even rook takes g4 and f3 i'm sure it
breaks through these rooks are just not helping
the queen side they're not helping the king's side
either no and i guess danny's trying to rely and
look at that move knight of a very smart move by
lawrence because knight takes g2 was the move that
i was first calculating but i guess what lawrence
want to avoid was white pushing the pawn to h3 and
getting a pawn to g4 keeping the position closed
here you can't do that because your knight's under
attack and you would just lose the focus yeah
this this is uh you guys can see the eval bar uh
shimmying right down the board there uh which
is because there there's no material imbalance
he's about to win a piece but up till now it's
about minus three minus four and he hasn't taken
anything yeah that's when you know you're in a
tough spot when the position is even in terms of
material but just completely hopeless in terms
of the game itself and well i wonder if danny
is going to sacrifice this knight yeah he is so
yeah that that's a good idea considering the time
situation and considering the board state like
even though blacks have a piece what next is the
real question uh the h file is definitely like
rook h6 and you know g5 and and rook down is
definitely an idea uh bishop g5 is tricky though
and danny he's looking to weasel his way in there
that was a good try but that's why lawrence
played g6 because both of his rooks covered
the a7 square so a nice last-ditch effort and the
funny thing about bishop b6 is you could also just
kind of sit there and laugh at it because it isn't
threatening anything anyway but as you mentioned
lawrence did have that covered laterally which is
uh uh something that paid off for him in the end
for sure and well a one game lead for lawrence i
wonder if we will see that french again it looks
a bit iffy to me but lawrence clearly prepared it
and moved very quickly in the opening look at this
i mean these guys are holding back nothing
right now yeah i mean how quick like what's
more impressive than how quickly he played g4
it was how quickly danny responded as if this
is something that he sees all the time right
it's just like oh east thorn is king side pawn
at me now no big deal play in the center
that is though strategically how we advise
people to handle things like that if someone's
attacking on a flank you don't necessarily need
to turtle up and defend on the flank you can
actually strike back in the center and that
counter attack is a form of defense so the the
first thing that i'm thinking is e4 here and i'm
i'm like why is this not good if i can cement
this pawn in any way and force white to play
either like d3 or f3 i'm feeling great right now
that knight seems like come to e5 and it's like
this feels devastating already right because 95
now especially after 92 it's like a self made
look at lawrence's face because knight d4 covers
both squares but just c5 right and lauren said
his head in his hands just devastated about how
bad his position is on move nine with the white
people this is the worst worst opening i have seen
in a good minute yeah and it's not quite over yet
i think that he has to play bishop g2 and even
if he knight d3 check put his king on f1 and you
hope that you can survive but as long as there's
no immediate checkmate the game isn't concluded
at least not at this point yeah the i think the
issue is that you're i mean after queen f6 in that
position you're gonna like you're gonna have to
play knight f4 basically yeah uh i don't envy this
position but lawrence he put his head in his hands
he was upset he needs to calm himself down because
there is still plenty of game left especially in a
blitz game i know four and a half minutes may seem
like an eternity especially to those of us who
play hyper bullet all the time but that's not that
much time to figure out the complications yeah and
we talked about you know like emotional turbulence
and how that might play in i think lawrence
was really feeling himself after that last one
shoves that the jeep on up the board you know
ready to get danny in another tricky opening
and all of a sudden he's like wait you know i
gotta i gotta maybe reign it in a little bit
you can't play you know crazy wing attacks in
every game and have them work as somebody who
plays some of the most suspicious openings ever i
know how it feels to play something that's offbeat
and then you're still down a lot of time because
it backfires and that's exactly what's happening
here but to lawrence's credit he went knight f4
he's about even on time that e4 pawn while it is
a strength if you say play queen takes f4 white
just plays d3 opening that bishop on c1 or even
d4 to a discovered attack on that queen so the f4
pawn remains white's king feels safer than they
did just a couple moves ago black i still would
prefer to play from danny's side of this position
but there's plenty of life left and you have a
lot to prove yeah once this bishop gets out um
i'm thinking f5 and and the rooks come into the
middle the the tough thing about this position
for lawrence is that danny's moves are not
complicated uh he he can bring the bishop out to
the most logical square uh just put a rook on d8
and he's not gonna be doing anything wrong you're
totally right and well it is not complicated
it seems like very straightforward moves but
you don't want to burn clock playing those type of
moves and that's the thing about blitz you have to
weigh playing quickly versus perfection and i
think for most players that i want to play the
best moves possible every single turn oftentimes
the move that are coming to these very strong
players quickly are they're often the best moves
the bishop of five is a move danny could have
played in four seconds and said he played it in
34 seconds exactly yeah and and if that pattern
keeps up for other moves of you know similar ease
then all of a sudden danny has like a minute and
you know a couple more couple more simple
moves so i think he's really gonna look to
um well actually he could even trade here and
i don't think he'd be upset i think queen e6
looks like the more maybe the nastier move yeah
yeah but even trading i think the end game is
just crushing for for black as well totally with
you and and this is what danny knight needs to
calculate is there some kind of queen takes
g7 check or does white have to spend a move
with the bishop first queen takes g7 will not
work though sometimes it might here it will not
but that's what danny is now calculating uh you
know can i just move a king over with king h8 the
answer seems to be a clear yes but then there's
bishop takes e4 as a possibility so the tactics
are really becoming a part of this position and
now danny is going to spend more time despite the
fact that he has a much better position i could
see this turning because of the complications
yeah and the nice thing to keep in mind for
black is that if this pawn ever disappears and
you're not getting mated you're actually really
happy to see that you throw in like a bishop h3
check followed by queen c4 check operate on the
e file with the rook and suddenly the white king
is like hey you know we're supposed to leave that
pawn there guys that's that's part of the shelter
completely agreed so that makes king h8 even more
likely of a move because bishop takes e4 as amman
was saying bishop h3 checks the possibility
but look at this bishop g6 played after about
a minute think still a very good move clogging
the g-file but it's one of these moves where like
is danny going to go on the defensive now or
is he just fending off the initial attack and
then countering himself yeah because all you
need um is to buy just that little bit of time
and after f5 i think lawrence is just hoping to go
to an end game although i don't think his chances
are too much better in an end game here like
queen takes f5 i think that that looks just fine
i'm wondering why bishop takes f5 because the only
response the bishop takes if i sees bishop takes
e4 but i'm taking your advice of hey actually
i want that pawn off the board so go ahead and
take it yeah the thing is bishop takes f5 is such
a hard move to make because you just played bishop
g6 right so to go back and play the exact same
position where it's your opponent's turn it's like
uh no not for me i'm with you it's much easier to
sit as a commentator and suggest that move because
i don't have to deal with the repercussion of
the attack but danny says hey iman is just being
very logical here let's go to this end game and
it's not quite a pure end game because still
many pieces on the board but look at white's
bishop on c1 that's hardly a bishop that's a
big pawn sitting there can't get out the
d-pawn is backwards you know would love
to play move like d4 but you just lose
a pawn on the spot with on passant so
yeah this is no good danny's got a good handle in
this position but one thing about bishop g6 which
you know does allow is a4 and previously there was
always bishop d7 to hit the rook hit that a pawn
and just always be a general nuisance on the light
squares so a4a5 is exactly what lawrence needs to
at least have a target on the queen side
and say look danny you know you might you
might be winning this game but at least there's
something you always have to keep your eye on
totally good point and i like how danny responds
instantly with rook to d6 saying i'm never going
to take you on a5 because while that shatters my
pawn structure it also gives this bishop on c1
a new lease on life that bishop if it goes to a3
now it attacks nothing the pawn on c5 is defended
by this pawn chain so that is what danny is doing
he's keeping that bishop on c1 in tuned by the
rest of the pawn structure and so lawrence is
just making moves at this point but now okay h5
that's a risky move because at some point perhaps
rook g5 will come in for now richie finds me by
bishop f6 so it seems that danny has everything
covered but you are creating some more weaknesses
yeah if this bishop stays on c1 the whole game
i mean let's be clear it's it's going to be a
loss for lawrence because the pawns on the queen
side keep it locked out the bishop a3 diagonal
doesn't go anywhere and that pawn on e4 you and
i were talking about that move was it like move
six or seven like ages ago like oh that looks
like a good one and now it's actually keeping
white completely locked down here in quarantine if
you will for sure there's really very little that
white can do here besides shuffle so that begs
the question what is black going to do to win this
game because the position looks great it is great
but how do we actually end this game decisively
i'm looking at bishop f4 as a nice move to control
g5 hit d2 just kind of get on a nicer square
bishop f6 uh hits the h4 pawn but i i like bishop
f4 for some reason just just hitting that d2 pawn
and taking control of some some squares there the
one thing about bishop f4 is white gets this d4
type of move as now ambassador is met by hanging
bishop on f4 so even though white has to give up
on in those sequences maybe that's worth it to
at least trade off your worst piece and that's
an interesting note i think for our audience is
that isn't the material more important or is it
the quality of our pieces yep and the quality of
white species has certainly been in question for
the majority of this game bishop takes c3 is let's
say it's on the cards but it looks like lawrence
is he does some bishop h5 uh move he wants to
throw in now it doesn't work yeah it's just a free
just a pawn yeah and danny takes it he has
45 seconds plenty of time left on his talk
actually he's really played a nice game keeping
lawrence stuck in the box and then taking material
when it was offered to him and lawrence i don't
think saw that coming he's clearly been frustrated
with his position and danny should be able to even
the score as this game uh nears its conclusion yep
yeah i don't see a good way to continue here
maybe he's gonna go rook b7 or rook a6 to try to
prevent black from taking on d2 ah it was
king f1 so bishop d2 there's bishop b2 check
and something that king on f6
isn't quite so safe check me yeah
that's uh that's a funny mate if you move the
gang rook takes g6 as robert's pointing out and
king has nowhere to go bishop back to e5 are
we going to see d4 we're going to get another
game that's another mate on e7 oh no d4 is a very
good move he plays d3 so what it's a oh it's one
of those moves where obviously your plans bishop
to g5 check but he chose the less forcing option
and d3 clearly was not the right move and we can
see with the evaluation bar going back down in
black's favor because look at danny he shuts that
bishop down from c1 that's what he's been going
against the entire game and now the d-pawn can't
move because the bish 1d1 is hanging behind it
no great great point and now i'm really concerned
for lawrence's position after just rook d3
and brook d1 yeah rook d1 just scoops off two
bishops for the rook and there might actually
be a checkmate right the king goes to g2 pawn
f3 would be checkmate so he goes to e2 instead
nice game yeah this has been a really nice game
from uh from danny here and and if king d2 there
was bishop f4 check which is why he's gone he's
gone to e3 is bishop for checkmate actually so
so many weird mates in this game yeah oh man these
bishops are gonna wreak havoc here rook b2 danny
i think has got this game under control yeah i'm
not too worried about his ability to win this one
the bishop on d4 i think you can call that
a great piece we'll go with great for now
and now the pawn's just rolling yeah
bishops cover way too many squares here
and just a great game the funny thing about
the the final position is you don't even have
stalemate tricks because you have the d1 square
yeah it's checkmated one threatened and the
king's just locked in but as you said that's very
important to point out though because it's easy to
think oh i'll just push my pawn go for checkmate
and then you don't realize your opponent just
sacrifices the rooks and makes a stalemate
but wasn't available there and hey we have this
french again yeah i think already we've seen the
first adaptation as danny has gone for a quicker
e5 than last time so he didn't let the knight
get to f6 first instead he played e5 preemptively
and it was met with f6 uh by lawrence and he puts
his quinceanera i see the evaluation bar went down
in black's favor which means that knight takes
d4 and then e5 is attacked here and i would not
have seen that immediately myself but when i see
the evaluation bar going down there must be some
tactic otherwise it doesn't make sense that black
would be so favored here yeah and knight takes
knight takes e5 queen takes e5 is just met by
brook e8 which backs up uh robert's tactic there
and it's just one of those situations where you're
trying to do a little too much in the opening
developing the queen when you know you got that
tender pawn and the way that black's opening works
with that knight c6 is they generally don't go for
c5 the the moves for black are usually revolving
around some sort of e5 break so tactically black
should be on the lookout for tactics revolving
around the e5 break in general a little bit more
than c5 so that was an option there for lawrence
he doesn't see it plays queen d6 he wants to play
e5 a little bit more organically it looks like and
it's impossible to blame somebody for not finding
that and i'm serious the only reason i saw it was
i quickly looked and i saw that the evaluation bar
plummeted and i was like okay that means there's a
tactic and it's such a simple position we're gonna
move eight so what else could there be besides a
night sacrifice just to break open the position so
i you know can't fault either of the players for
overlooking that that's one of the things where
once you realize it's possible you're like oh
okay never again but to even think about it as
being a possibility is something that you really
have to train yourself uh to master absolutely
um we've seen asics so lawrence has actually
taken a much slower approach than the eval bar
would would like him to uh but also bishop d7
bishop e8 bishop h5 as long as that might take
is a very common maneuver you might look at the
e5 break and say well that's not happening what
am i going to do with this light square bishop
that's usually the maneuver either to put it on g6
or more commonly h5 where it's going to pin that
knight and then the d4 pawn really becomes tender
completely agreed and speaking of tender d4
pawn now the bishop's on a5 at some point
you have to watch out for bishop to b6 putting
another attacker right there in the center and
i like your idea with bishop b7 first i don't
think you have to rush this bishop to b6 decision
because that would later invite knight a4
type of stuff so i would play bishop d7
you can either put your rook or your bishop on
e8 depending on how white responds and i think
that lawrence considering uh you know the state
of this position he should be perfectly happy
yeah and bishop d7 even if you don't go for bishop
e8 bishop h5 i think the bishop just needs to go
there anyway you're not going to play b6 in this
position with your bishop on a5 uh b5 doesn't look
any better so i think your bishop just needs to
go to d7 if not just to connect the rooks and he
plays bishop to b6 he does the immediate pressure
on the d4 pawn and i guess white's only move to
defend his bishop e3 at this point not exactly
move you want to play because the semi-open
e file was yours for the taking now you're
blocking your own queen's access along the line
yeah and now i guess bishop d7 makes sense as
well i think white's gonna get you know the rooks
look pretty good on sort of e1 d1 but i think i
think bishop e8 bishop h5 is something to really
uh worry about or something that you need an
answer to simply he goes knight g4 because
instead of the slower which i i liked your plan
a lot with bishop d78 he says rook takes f3 is a
big threat trying to checkmate you over there on
h2 and it's not just the uh sacrificing exchange
there's also a d4 pawn hanging because the knight
is really needed on f3 to defend the king side so
by process of elimination i'd say g3 is the move
that white has to play in which case your eventual
bishop getting involved in light squares
is going to be even more powerful
as g3 makes the remaining light squares weaker yep
no that's well said g3 um basically if you go h3
if lawrence wanted to he could still sack on f3
white would take on g4 and then he'd probably
just bring the rook back somewhere and say okay
your d-pawn is weaker as a result and not so sure
that that pawn on on g4 is going to be a good
thing exactly because that semi-open h5 would
be good if white had a rook there but when the
king's over there that could cause some problems
and as you point out the d4 pawn remains
a target for lawrence to pile up on so
i mean g there's really not a move you want
to play here for white so i could understand
why danny would go h3 just to avoid weakening
the light squares but it does come with the
cost of that d4 pawn becoming pretty proud what
about bishop takes h7 like because he's spending
time that has to be the move he's considering
here other than pawn moves in front of the king
well issue h7 uh the point is that if king takes
h7 knight g5 check you win that knight back on g4
i kind of like that i mean i really didn't put
much stock into it at first i wasn't thinking
along those lines but that's on me that's me
overlooking a tactic that could be good he does
it so king h8 is definitely what i was gonna say
regardless of what happens i think that's the move
he was going to play but i think maybe we needed a
more energetic response from lawrence like taking
that bishop allowing queen g4 and just trying
like e5 queen h5 bishop f5 something like that i'm
with you that's like in the style of the french
where you get that bishop out you feel good about
your position here queen h5 probably just lands
checkmate in a couple moves because your king's
stuck in the corner here ooh that's bad knight
f7 and then after check you have bishop takes
h6 if he tries to sneak that knight into block
i think danny is is going to get lawrence here
i'm trying to try to find like the best way to
continue playing here and i'm kind of struggling
because there's checkmate on e8 as well right like
if rook f6 you play bishop g6 check and then just
check on h7 with your queen check on h8 with your
queen and then mate on e8 in the end i know it's
may be hard to visualize for some more audience
but it's a very forcing sequence so lawrence yeah
he's pretty much out of options here and that's a
pretty funny kind of checkmate black has you know
six seven pieces around the king and the
white's queen is just waltzing in like
yeah that's uh never fun when you
have that especially when you're
up more material than lawrence is currently up
because he's up a piece right now for one pawn
and yeah you're up like three pieces you're
like oh i'm winning oh this is happening yeah
well if anyone had trouble visualizing
hopefully danny is going to be able to
show you exactly what robert meant yep this is
the exact checkmate and he's gonna allow it yeah
see there that's how you know danny and i
unfortunately have becoming more in sync
with one another well actually maybe this is
fortunate for him and unfortunate for me where
he is now finding these direct checkmates and you
know he's doing as i said and the match actually
has come to a pause because in the i'm not a
gm speech championship there is a break for
the players midway through the time segments
so with that in mind any final thoughts on the
first three games that we've seen here before we
had a break well what we've seen uh because we've
only seen three games we've only seen the white
pieces um for danny twice so lawrence hasn't had
his second game with white and what we've seen
is the french every time and uh what i'm seeing
from these positions so far is that i'm actually
liking them for for lawrence the way that they're
they're trending i think that he has a lot
of opportunities that he can capitalize on
in general uh we haven't necessarily seen them
danny uh played a great good game this time uh
but he did give up some tactical shots on the way
in a break i can see lawrence take taking a look
at these games and being like i'm gonna keep
playing this opening i'm not unhappy with the
evals the positions that i'm getting against danny
i mean if you're getting these types of positions
with the french robert i think you have to keep
playing it um the way the match is going so far
i'm with you i feel like the first two games the
results were fair both players dominated the games
they won and this third game was more of a toss-up
where danny uncorked a tactic because lawrence
himself was the one who went for adventurous uh
opportunities so what with that we'll take a quick
break we will return with more from this i'm not
a gm speed chess championship brought to you by
chess.com
and we return with more action from the i'm not
a gm speeches championship i'm on danny wrench
the beloved chess.com chief chess officer uh
commentator just personal extraordinaire he is out
to a 2-1 lead over lawrence trent himself a very
famous well-known commentator so danny has to feel
happy thus far but you and i were talking during
the break for lawrence you don't think he should
be too upset about his play either no i mean let's
first give credit where credit's due not only did
uh danny win the most recent game before the break
but he also had what i would say is maybe the most
dominating game that we've seen so far in the
match which was game two with those two bishops
and the way he just punished lawrence's maybe over
aggressive opening with the white pieces so we're
interested to see what lawrence comes up with with
the white pieces we know he's going to adjust he's
not going to repeat that line exactly but yeah
and if you're in lawrence's camp i don't think
you're too unhappy the score is two to one you're
only down a game you haven't even had the white
pieces twice yet and uh i think that both games
with the french although he's one-on-one with it
i think he can be happy with the positions he's
getting and if he uses that break even to just
check a few computer evaluations or maybe review
his lines there i think he'll be happy with what
he finds yeah i'm with you there partner and i
do think that game two was one where lawrence is
not going to be repeating that g4 g5 is sort
of i'm hyper aggressive but it backfires in
two moves because danny put his pawn e4 his knight
on e5 and everything started looking terrible
for lawrence who had the white pieces in that
game so i think we'll see something different
from him maybe something more initially
solid before storming for an attack but
hey we have liftoff and c4 once again is played
yep so i think he's generally okay with g4
but he's really i mean he's checked this let's
let's be clear this this has to be different
than last time and there we go he's got d3 he's
checked it and he says look this is still playable
i trust myself here what do you make what's your
initial take on d3 you know he's clearly prepped
this in the break is this something that you're
feeling confident about well lawrence must have
played this before and the reason i say that is
because danny is coming and playing really quickly
in response to this obscure opening so he must
have seen lawrence's database of games said this
is something he might play against me and thus i
feel ready to handle it but it's just such a weird
dynamic where it feels like black is the one who
has all the immediate pressure look at this pawn
on d3 you can't play bishop g2 like you want to
because then you drop the d3 pawn immediately so
i had this feeling that this should be pretty
good for black from both a an objective point
of view but also just a strategic point of view
it seems easier to my eyes for black to play yep
yep i'm i'm with you there because well we might
even see just like queen d7 or something from from
black i'm not sure how scary queen b7 is supposed
to be and we do see queen d7 um if white can sort
of sneak in a bunch of moves in a row like he gets
his knight to g3 and then plays bishop e2 i could
believe some light square control with h4h5 coming
and bishop on g6 but as we see he's got to play
rook d1 he's got to defend his pawn on d3 before
he can do that stuff it just feels like if you can
get everything you want it's a nice structure but
um i can't see that happening in an easy way here
yeah i think that you know you would ideally
be able to capture this pawn on b7 you can't
do that because rook b8 is a very straightforward
response winning the bishop behind the queen on
b2 that's why lawrence edward brooke to d1 and
yeah he has the d3 pawn defended for the moment
and one of the big questions that danny is trying
to ponder here is should he castle queenside that
gets the king out of the center connects the
rooks but perhaps on the queen side the king is
in danger but i think on the king side it's also
going to be in danger so he says hey let's do this
yep he castles along at adds even more pressure
immediately to that d-pawn now i don't know if
it's actually something that can be captured
but at least you know it needs consideration and
lawrence gives it about two seconds of
consideration and says uh you can't take it and
if you really want to you can calculate it well i
think one of the big problems is if you are going
to take this pawn on d3 you need to have the move
e5 to e4 as a follow-up to defend the bishop on
that square but e4 is not a possibility with the
bishop hanging on g7 behind the pawn so that's why
danny does not take it instead plays bishop
to g4 which threatens bishop f3 for example
not only does it pin the knight but can you plant
the bishop there kick the rook out of the corner
so i mentioned how black's king might not be
saved but amman is white's king really going
to be any safer here yeah well at this point
i think it's fair to say that um white's not
playing on castling now he could of course go
some sort of bishop g2 thing but yeah rook g1
feels much more natural he's using one rook to
defend d3 the other rook to operate on the g-file
and he's saying look although there's an
open d file here otherwise the position is
it's not too open like the king doesn't have
diagonals to worry about this a5 e1 can't see
black taking advantage of that so actually bishop
takes e2 king takes e2 if that were to happen i
think lawrence's king is just fine in the center
of the board completely agreed and one thing that
white needs to figure out because there's a bishop
on g2 a queen on b3 you want to kick that knight
out of c6 and one way that you would try to do
that is playing d4 but not with that king on e1
absolutely not right d4 would be way too risky
blowing open the center when your king is on e1
bishop takes e2 for instance so i think that
lawrence is going to need to figure out a way
to actually increase his attack but as you're
pointing out his king seems all right here on e1
yeah and if danny basically gets the move um f4
in even if it loses a pawn or something we know at
this moment that lawrence's king is not going to
the left or the right it's stuck in the middle so
i think if you just open the position generally
speaking definitely a good thing for for danny
for sure and he brings that rook to e8 saying
f4 becomes even more powerful you're certainly
not taking enough for that situation because
the rook opens up but the downside of playing
f4 is that the e4 square becomes whites
for the taking and while the initial
concrete attack is more valuable to black in the
long run if you can fend off the attack then put a
bishop or knight eventually on e4 that would be
good news for lawrence yeah we see f3 which is
definitely not my first take on the position but
you sort of see what he wants to do he wants to
free the the knight on e2 to move if necessary
like knight c3 um he goes bishop c3 to follow
up so at some point he might just go like e4
solidify like that that bishop on d5 and and try
to play that position i'm trying to see what other
intentions you might have with f3 he's i guess he
wants to get rook b1 in and if the pawn we're not
in f3 right now you put that palm back in f2 there
could be something bishop takes e2 and knight
d4 check i know that may be difficult for our
audience but that was one of the ideas potentially
though that knight can't really move i mentioned
this earlier that is pretty stuck on c6 so i
don't think that would have worked and now the
e3 pawn is a target so i actually like how this is
turning for danny yeah and in response to rook b1
uh i think just b6 is all like is that all that
uh that black has to to guard that pawn because
if so i feel like i would be throwing rook b1 in
yeah b6 is a really scary move to have to play but
you're right that's what the response would have
been and i'm with you because now the king's in
f2 you still have rook to b1 as an option but i
don't really like the look of this king sitting
on f2 for example f4 and maybe queen h3 at some
point can be really scary for this king on f2
yeah and and i'm wondering why like okay so
how does black meet rook be one in a good way
um i see the eval bar definitely favoring black
and it looks like one of those positions that
that should favor him but after rook b1 like
b6 queen a4 like i start to get pretty pretty
concerned with uh black's position and that's
exactly why danny went bishop f7 saying well now
you play rook b1 i will play b6 but you don't have
time to use amman's plan of queen to b5 and queen
a4 and get in on those light squares because
a bishop trait is being offered on d5 so i'm
with you about it felt like this was just a move
too slow for lawrence to pry open the queen side
yeah because bishop h6 i mean although it
threatens e3 that's not a check so you could
play rook b1 and then king f2 or and then queen a4
and then king f2 there's a lot of maybe in between
moves that could have been thrown in there and you
always want to think about the weaknesses you may
create or you know what kind of tempo you may gain
and here i think white should play e4 himself and
say let me keep that bishop on d5 you mentioned
that idea the thing i don't really love about
is once say this pawn moves away from f5 that
queen can jump into h3 and that's just king on f2
that king is not happy to be there yeah and if
you take with the f pawn ever you're just asking
for it not only is the e3 square guarded by h3 as
well the f files just opened up on your king so
um very very scary actually and i know this is
kind of weird but after e4 i'm also a little
concerned about strangely move like bishop f8
and like maybe coming to c5 that's another good
point because maybe you can even clog the b-file
with the bishop if white allows it and just to
safeguard this king on c8 so multiple options
here for danny he is a little bit ahead on the
clock but i think that honestly white's position
somehow is easier to play because either you're
getting checkmated or the situation the center
is so clumped in there that i think it actually
helps white play a little more quickly and black
has to figure out what's going on yeah definitely
definitely and the big decision because if
you take on e4 here d takes e4 and suddenly
that d file is opened up right on your queen
you have to you have to make the right decision
whether that's something you want to allow or
not because it's very committal it can't go back
yeah i mean i really want to get my queen
to h3 but i recognize that there are some
tactical difficulties in these variations
so danny trying to figure it out he is now
down quite a bit of time and i'm looking at
him with his gaming goggles on he's trying
to uh work through this and you pick queen e7 to
head over to h4 and maybe to c5 as you mentioned
uh that f8 a3 diagram could be useful for
a check on c5 at some point yeah and and
danny really looks like um some sort of like
40 year old cyberpunk character right now
which is an interesting look he's going
for yeah he also looks like he could be
in pokemon with that glove absolutely he
he looks like he was like the first trainer
oh my gosh he would have
loved to hear you say that so
too bad he's playing and not joining us in the
call but yeah he does bring his queen to c5 this
king is going to slide over to okay it goes to g2
just to give you e2 to h1 and the thing is once
white solves the king like once a king gets to
g2 slash h1 i mean there's nothing to worry about
there now it's like wait a minute i'm kind of safe
let's full send that attack we were talking about
and rook b1 yeah he's going right for it and
queen this is an idea that amman was mentioning
10 moves ago or so and now it's finally
happening exactly your point that the light
squares are really vulnerable that bishop
on d5 somehow has survived way too long
i know and this bishop on g6 and h6 both look kind
of unimpressive at the moment i think you have to
take the bishop on d5 with the rook i was i was
thinking about that this looks like bishop takes
a5 and queen c6 is in the air rook b5 in the air
oh gosh but which one right that's the he takes
it yeah i feel like rook b5 and rook takes a5 was
the way to go okay so if you take on a5 the pawn
captures black's pawn structure looks bad but the
king can at least escape so yep he does take it
he could have thrown a bishop b7 check first
that would have won an exchange oh yep that's
oh that would have been cool but now look at
danny's room five yep oh that works coming to b2
king h3 no he goes to h1 wait why did he give
the a pawn he could have oh there's a discovered
check i guess so he goes like this we give him
all his pawns yeah well strangely enough that
king might run like all the way to h3 it's kind of
hilarious wait that actually might be a good idea
it's not insane no it actually looks
really good with the g5 definitely to g5
yeah kg5 king h4 was a serious idea yeah he's
hopped up on getting that rook to b2 but white's
not gonna let that happen so easily no and king
h6 a little bit too late to get the king to h3
perhaps but he can still go for it yep the problem
is that rook on c8 can't get involved right you'd
have to go rook c5 rook c to a5 and then try to do
something like that oh there's a bit of panic here
from from lawrence he can't defend that a pawn
in a good way king g5 let's go kg5 is actually
begging to be played at this point to get rid of
the pin take that i'll take it in rock a6 yeah
and now he's taking a6 anyway yeah yeah he
can't danny's tandy wants that king back like
really badly wait now obstacle
bishops oh you didn't take the pawn
and it's the wrong color h-pawn just
for the record yeah i have to say that
you know make sure everybody notices
it's the wrong color h pawn for both guys
unfortunately it's not going to matter for danny i
don't think so this is going to be bishop back to
e4 and f6 or just bring that king yeah here comes
the king to help usher the pawn to the other side
that should promote relatively soon yeah
bishop f2 at least try yeah tough tough
yeah now look at the dominance white's
up three pawns and all the pieces are
doing well here yeah and and lawrence is
keeping everything protected by something
and with f7 and c7 being threats i don't think
we're going to see a brick g8 so you can promote
next and there we go we see a promotion no
stalemates no tricks and that's an even match
wow and 2-2 just like that lawrence it i felt
like he really sees the opportunity as soon as
the king got to g2 you could feel like you
know lauren's kind of sitting up in the chair
being like wait a minute my king's safe
now danny you're dead on the queen side
you know that was a obviously none of these
games are going to be perfect no matter
who's playing in a blitz competition there are
going to be some mistakes but that was a pretty
well initiated attack by lawrence just
the what we saw stemming from the opening
keeping up the pressure and it was very difficult
for danny to fend off the ensuing pressure
yeah and we see in this game lawrence has gone
for the french again and he's even changed
some of his lines he's just gone wait a minute
why don't i go bishop d6 and just e5 that's the
way i think this line was intended to be played
and every time i see this this line uh robert i'm
just like why is danny playing this none of these
positions look good at all no this black's already
castled you don't even have an isolated pawn
which would usually be the drawback of playing
an e5 type of move so right black's pawn structure
healthy the pieces are active and coordinated and
white isn't doing badly and probably will castle
queen side i guess but it takes a bit of time yeah
i mean usually this pawn on c6 you take it and you
just put it on f7 and that's like a position that
maybe is playable for black put that on c6 you
got a great pawn chain you got the open f file
i think you're just uh sailing here with the
black knight e4 this is really good for black
i completely agree because you know bishop
takes e4 black will get an isolated pawn on
e4 once you recapture but keep those queens
on the board play for the initiative here
blackwell both bishops really active the
rook on fade is staring at f2 no this is
not how you want your opening to go from the white
side of a french yeah this is just crazy like
bishop e3 almost looks like it has to be played if
you don't take that knight and then queen g6 just
attack g2 i don't see too many good ways to defend
it if you castle you're castling right into bishop
takes h3 no and if you play rook g1 there's like
bishop h2 to kick that rock oh that's that's cruel
that's cool yeah this is this is no fun and
you can also tell by danny's clock usage
that he's not enjoying his position at all this is
unacceptable like i don't think you can be playing
e4 e6 and letting this happen against what is
basically just a sideline yes and it's honestly
black's life is too easy here just look at this
you want bishop g5 just to go back to e3 you
should have played bishop e3 right away and then
you wouldn't have all these difficulties and it's
interesting because black isn't like completely
winning yet but no every single aspect of this
position is favorable for black you've already
castles you have a semi-open file that you can
work with but the semi-open d-file you're already
slow to get there and it's a pawn chain all well
defended so the minor pieces better for black
more active nah no fun no fun queen g6 rook e8
is gonna happen um if i'm white here i think that
i like i just want to castle um i want to castle
queen side because i'm i'm honestly i'm too scared
to castle king's side let's put put it that way
i think you're right to be skeptical there might
be like a very quick mate and castle kingston i
don't even think bishop takes h3 right away yeah
i'm sure it's at least fine if not winning right
so you have to end up casting queen side but there
might be knight takes f2 tactics which is why
uh not lauren so danny is currently thinking here
because castle queen side you move your king away
from the defense of the pawn knight takes f2
when the bishop moves away from f5 the rook on
f8 will then be opened up to that f2 square so i
believe that tactic will work out in black's favor
yeah yeah so even if long castle's here knight
f2 right away is that what you're saying
yes yeah that that is probably what danny's going
through right now um at i would say a slower pace
than we are which is why the clock is ticking
and ticking he doesn't want to castle king's side
looks too scary and he's like well i gotta go
queen side and then he's evaluating he's like
wait a minute knight f2 and i'm i'm probably in
trouble there which is why he landed on rook f1
you know that's a very difficult
move to play psychologically because
it's you know obviously now you have to castle
queen side because you can't castle king such a
movie of rook and the sole purpose of the move is
to defend the pawn which is what you need but then
he's saying well actually what's lawrence's
response here how is he going to increase
his potential in the position take advantage of
the fact that i haven't casted yet because casting
queenside is happening next and i'm not quite
sure how black fully stops it and he played c5 wow
yeah i think he wants to go for c4 try to
force that light squared bishop off the board
but rook f1 is one of those moves that never feels
good to play when you haven't castled at least one
in the other direction because it's almost the
move that you play when you try to castle as
a kid and you accidentally touch your rook first
and then arbiter comes by and says sorry you gotta
move your rook and you're like oh man i gotta play
rook f1 you know what's happened to the best of us
so yep speaking from experience over here yep
been there and look at that bishop takes c5 not
pieces not defended well look at lawrence he
did not see that coming at all he's like what
am i doing my position was perfect and now i'm
pushed upon and then it was captured immediately
yeah and what a weird tac like you just don't
see that in chess too often that some one guy
really has the upper hand the the other side
isn't castled you just kind of expand the the
pawns in the center and all of a sudden one just
gets picked off that's such a weird feeling yeah
i think it stems from playing with like your
intuition rather than with your thought and it's
not to be overly critical of lawrence but c5 is a
good move if not for the fact that your bishop on
f5 was not well defense you always want to look
for loose pieces danny was able to steal the pawn
on c5 bring the bishop right back but this isn't
over right bishop f4 stops away from castling
and he plays b5 it also makes casting a little
bit harder because there's a potential attack
but i think that lawrence despite blundering upon
there he still has plenty of opportunity to create
a legitimate attack but i think we've talked about
this before is that um you were mentioning to me
in the break that the previous bishop h7 that
he sort of missed in the in the game where he
got checkmated very quickly after he missed the
tactic he sort of responded very quickly and it's
sometimes a bit of an ego thing you don't
want to tell your opponent that you missed
something it's like oh yeah that was part of
my plan and i saw that move and here he kind
of got his pocket picked on c5 and i loved your
bishop f4 move that would have been the follow-up
if you just spent a little bit of time and said
okay let me make the best of this next position i
blundered upon but hey bishop f4 i'm still in this
game allowing danny to castle here he just kind of
chucked b5 out as a as a response to losing a pawn
and i don't think it was the the best he could do
and now he's just suffering opposite bishops we
might see the same type of game that lawrence just
won but now it's danny's turn and we were talking
about a position just like this but with a black
pawn f7 right you give essentially the equal
material and you play against an isolated pawn
now white's also up a pawn and the king on b1
is perfectly safe it's not very easy to play
a5 and then b4 because white can probably
just pick off this b5 pawn at some point so
lawrence is grasping at straws to create an
attack here and you're right i think it is
not to specifically say that lawrence is the
sole person who uh falls victim to this but
we all do when we play something we're like oh we
overlooked it let me just make a quick response so
my opponent doesn't think that i'm a fool and
i'm blundering no i'm gonna do something quick so
it seems like wait what was what was he thinking
what's he planning here but in reality no this
was another blunder and as you said a quick
follow-up that should have uh been a position
where lord said you know it's not so bad for me
despite the fact that i did make a big mistake
yeah not at all and the position we have here
is going to be one where lawrence is going to
put pressure on the clock that's that's his win
condition i think uh is the best way to put it um
h4 played i think danny's looking for h5
positionally speaking i would be really
interested in g3 and then f4 uh but h5 is the you
know aggressive attacking way to finish things off
yeah and at some point knight takes d3 can be a
consideration but you don't really want to keep
yourself with an isolated pawn on d5 and it's
knight blockading it which is why he did play
bishop e5 here perhaps he'll take this
knight on d4 if you if white allows it
so if i'm danny i i probably wouldn't
allow it and that's why i played knight f3
and h5 yeah gotta be h5 i think he's just going
to continue yeah because if you move the g pawn
you lose the h7 pawn then d5 falls after that
this is no fun yeah and this king on b1 with
this pawn a3 b2 c3 setup so safe um i mean do
you play like crazy enough a5 here and just b4
you probably have to out of just sheer desperation
you go for that because white's king sitting safe
and sound the king on g8 now not exactly very
safe over there at some point you can swing
over the h file maybe now but he didn't just
go rookie one so it's clear that he's not cause
this is looking slow uh by danny rookie one rookie
two i feel like the b4 move is happening here
like yeah right now we have we haven't been paying
attention to the clock danny only has 18 seconds
left and that's why he's moving quickly look
at this knight c6 idea hitting the rook on b8
trying to take on b4 with the knight and if black
plays b3 at least the queen side is closed down
from the rook's infiltration yep no knight c6
is is important i think danny was counting on
this one so lawrence is going to go b3 and now
maybe brooke c8 rookie e8 both look wait there's
reasonable also bishop f4 hitting the queen and
the knight on c6 is not defending wow what a what
a discovered attack there yeah there's knight e7
in response oh that's it but that that has to be
what what you want to see because you can take on
d2 take on d3 take on f2 there i mean this could
get really wild with complications right all the
pieces and there it is bishop f4 97 chat probably
the only move he plays yeah wait you just dropped
the piece i don't think he realized it was hit
and i i simply don't think he noticed that and
if rook c6 is ideal rook h1 somehow to go i think
i think that is the i mean queen f6 seems to did
he not notice it either well maybe sing the oh 97
queen takes and then queen d4 oh that's so
nice oh he what oh took back okay your move
queen d4 is good though for sure okay so what do
we have here opposite bishops i mean my goodness
oh my gosh daddy oh that's heartbreaking stuff
wow oh my goodness uh there were
tactics all over the place and
yeah that was actually an insanely tactical game
like even missing some of the pieces uh that
were hanging it created even more tactics
for the next move right wow that that was
i don't really have anything more to say so we
have a new game where instead of playing for g4
and all this stuff it seems like we have a more
closed positional battle and i don't know who
that favors at least you know we don't have to
worry about these kind of crazy attacks just yet
but i can't get over that i think it favors us
in the commentary booth because we can just calm
down a little bit after that last blunder
that that was yeah that was bad so yeah and
you could tell danny is he's still thinking about
that this is one of those moments where the you
know like the the camera pans into danny's
mind and the screen blurs a little bit and
he's just flashbacks to blundering the rook
on e7 so he's really got to focus up here and
get a good game in because actually lawrence
has been on a roll ever since the break
he's come back he's won two games in a row
and and he's been he's been looking sharp that
that game clock is counting down and there's
only going to be so many games that you can get
in in the five-minute portion and you're totally
right that denny does need to collect himself here
because right now his position is perfectly good
right he is the one who is trying to make inroads
on his opponent's king the light squares for
white over there and that's why i played f5 he's
saying 96 okay your knight's in there but i'm
collapsing your center and if e4 can be chopped
down then d5 becomes a weakness then 96 and
over f7 just move my rook out of the way the
bishop is well defended on c5 so ultimately danny
moving quickly and it's turning out okay for him
in the current position but he needs to take a
breath because he is just about level in this
match he's down one point but it's because of just
blunders from both sides in that previous game
yeah i i think danny needs to focus up here
and not let the score run up too much in his
opponent's favor because i love his position um
take on e4 uh seems seems extremely reasonable and
i'm honestly even thinking about those lines where
you give up your bishop for this knight on d4
and just go like knight g6 bring a rope to e8
it just seems really really easy to play that's
like one option i like that plan because they're
often positions where your opponent has a bishop
and you have a knight and we hear oh the bishop
is so strong because it plays on both sides of the
board but there's no clear target like you look
at the pawn structure all these pawns are in dark
squares but the base pawn c7 and g7 is immune to
a bishop's attack from e3 or even if it gets to d4
so it seems like a good strategy for black to take
on before at some point to take on d4 as you said
and maybe maybe leave the tension maybe
you take on d4 and just play knight g6
and say maybe i'll play f4 for black if you're
not careful or i'll just take on e4 i like
leaving more pieces right in the position the
tension alive yeah so i think the biggest choice
is whether he includes fe or not because i i
think that okay he goes knight g6 uh important
to note that knight e6 isn't really possible
at the moment because the bishop is hanging
so i think he might be planning for a bishop takes
d4 type of position but he says look it's pinned
for the moment if you want to go knight c2 be my
guess the e5 square is mine and i'm just gonna
slowly you know bring the rook into e8 if this
queen ever moves really watch out for queen g4
uh by black and you know if you get queen g4
you hit the e pawn got knight h4 coming in
already looks pretty scary so lawrence has gotta
really watch for that g4 square and g4 and if the
queen moves say to e2 then the a4 square also is
one that that queen could jump to so the queen on
d1 doing an important job knight e5 of course
how should we play your knights under attack
bring that into the center here this
looks great for danny yep here we go
he might sneak that rook up somewhere like rook
f4 rook f5 yeah rook of four rook five looks
reasonable because especially on f4 if you capture
that the g pawn takes and then watch out for like
a king f3 rook g1 from white turning the tables
on black's king so rookie four's a really good
move i wouldn't be surprised if the response is
queen a4 i mentioned that as a possibility if the
queen left d1 and now feels like the moment yeah
no queen a4 is really important to to keep an eye
on the queen on d1 was like perfectly covering
everything but at some point you got to move
that queen to connect the rooks so he's chosen the
king's side b be on the lookout for robert's queen
a4 because that that could be the difference maker
in a lot of positions like takes on d4 followed by
queen a4 there's queen c2 check bishop's hanging
on d4 yeah and the e4 pawn as well so i i really
like danny's position he's trying to figure this
out and he looks like he likes his position the
way he's leaning in right now he's trying to
figure out what's the right way forward here
because there's so many different options but you
should remember that the knight can now move from
d4 before the bishop on e3 was hanging now the
knight can move because on g1 it's well defended
yep absolutely now the interesting thing is the
knight on e5 and the pawn on h6 work to cover
all the squares on the g file and the only
reason i mentioned that is after knight e6
i'm thinking how do i attack the g7 pawn with the
queen but there isn't really a good way to pursue
that attack so even if knight e6 happens and and
danny has to you know trade some pieces i don't
think it's that bad we could even just get the
queen in like queen a4 as you were mentioning and
uh i think it's still totally totally reasonable
for him agreed completely so that's maybe the
sort of the idea seems much stronger than it
actually is in practice with the knight coming
e6 so you can avoid it but what i don't
like is danny spending all this time here
yeah i think he's really conflicted about trading
on d4 or not like i'm not sure he's fully decided
um i think bishop g1 is one of those moves where
if you didn't play it then danny would make a
quicker move because he's like oh yeah i got that
knight pinned you know kind of like how he had it
last turn but bishop g1 says you know look you got
to make a serious decision though that knight's
jumping into e6 if you let me for sure and so
danny's still on the clock this is actually making
me a bit concerned for him because even if he
plays a good move here in the next bunch of moves
we just saw what happened in the last game he was
down to 18 seconds lawrence had about a minute and
a half and was able to use time as a weapon and
that could be the case once again and what do you
think of just takes takes queen a4 to look for
a more concrete line um because at this point i
think danny needs to start thinking about the fact
that two minutes is a lot of time when there's a
lot of pieces on the board simplifying might just
be better for the clock situation well i think he
spent all that time wisely because he did in fact
put his queen on a4 here he's saying i can take on
d4 next your knight cannot move because e4 hangs
with check to boot so it seems like this position
is turning in danny's favor and queen d1 is a
response that's not exactly the most inspiring
move but it's a very good practical move right and
wow what what a decision that was played quickly
so he wanted the two rooks there if queen takes a4
and that's probably what he was spending most of
his time on was not seeing that it's a possibility
but assessing it like would the two rooks be
better than the queen the answers seem to be yes
it gives a check on that f8 now do you trade q
i want to keep the queens in the board i feel
like white's king is weaker than black's king
so i would like to keep the queens in the war the
queen d7 type move right um queen c4 so same idea
and the question is after like rook
c1 i think he wants to play queen d3
that's actually quite annoying because there's so
many tactics there with that knight landing on d3
yep there's like rook c2 after trading
knight e1 the weirdest fork you've seen
absolutely and then you can consider taking
on d4 like all of these variations allow
if that knight doesn't move from d4 black can
still consider giving up the bishop for the
knight so i really like this move queen c4 and
12 lawrence is b3 to kick the queen the queen
jumps back and the a3 pawn becomes the
target as well so it's not that easy
for lawrence to make a move because there are
very concrete repercussions yep no matter what
yep i'm trying to find out what what move we want
to play here like looking at queen c2 strange
strange stuff hard move to play but perhaps
completely reasonable they might be just trading
queens and trading bishops and knight d3 still at
the end because b2 and the f2 square are available
uh for the black rook so he plays b4 well queen
a2 is is one move that comes to mind um yeah
and there's d4 so he takes here his knight
can go into after three queen eight uh
no queen eight two isn't it knight d or knight f3
you're gonna win the e4 pawn by force yeah that's
that's gotta be it and i would say probably f3
just because it leads to nastier stuff after
queen e4 and discoveries yeah and that's that b4
that's a it's one of those moves where you like
can't contain yourself so you just play something
that is forcing but then you immediately pay the
price and well this is the price yep yeah this is
and there's not even going to be time for counter
attack there's no tricky move to throw in uh for
a guy who has 20 seconds this is just i think it's
clear-cut danny's gonna take on e4 and he's going
to have just the bounce back game that he needs
yeah and you see danny's face he does look a lot
more into the match than he did at the start of
this game because he looked deflated after
losing game five now when you even the score
the momentum sort of shifts psychologically
in your favor it will be three to three if
he's able to convert this which seems pretty
straightforward at this point there's no tactic
available to white to confuse danny or anything
okay well that that'll confuse us but i don't
think it'll confuse danny no just take on
e4 one check on c7 good for you king back
to g8 that's that the white king's getting mated
very quickly yeah queenie won and just hope that
he messes the checks out yeah this is not gonna
so he could have a queen g2 but they need to
calculate do i actually want to sacrifice anything
like getting checkmated yeah g5 is classy and the
rook and queen coordinate for mate but i would
play knight age three mate robert after king g1
i like your style of mod knight 3 checkmate
was the fancier one and would have been great
and by the way we have what just over 10
minutes so if this game goes the distance
this will be our final game of the longest time
control and well we have a french once again
lawrence going back yeah i don't know what the
stats are on like games in the five minute portion
because i know that we have guys like you know
magnus and hikaru who are out here setting records
for the most games but i feel like we've almost
seen the least games yeah like for for a 75-minute
time patrol only seven games that that's
impressive because that's a serious average
yeah they're really slowly well it's because the
games have been quite tight right they've all
come down to the wire both sides down to about 20
seconds or so so it's been a close match i do not
like this opening okay danny needs a pep talk here
this is terrible it is so unacceptable i think i
agree with you because even knight g4 here looks
like a big problem for white it's almost winning
right because you're hitting f2 you're
hitting h2 queen h4 i mean this is
we're talking about games going the
distance this game might end very quickly
yeah i i don't know what danny is thinking
with this opening but i feel like he he
deflates himself because right after a good game
he always plays the white pieces and he plays this
sort of ridiculous french position that uh he
needs to change honestly in the break yeah this is
in f4 now the bishop just well queen h4 check
you lose the bishop on e5 even maybe that is
acceptable for black but if just bishop d6 white
has created all of these holes in the position if
you castle this bishop c5 check at the very least
picking up an exchange so i can't recognize let's
let's just put castle bishop c5 check king h1
queen h4 h3 um on the board i mean knight f2
queen takes after gg if not bishop takes h3
leading to more so right yeah that is uh something
he does not want to do he's played c3 i i don't
think i've seen it this is -5 according to the
engine robert that's an insane evaluation that's
really well i mean i guess just bringing the
queen in for a check if g3 queen h3 the queen
slithers into g2 hits the rook the h2 pawn
if white were already castle queenside i would
still think that black is better but the fact
that you can't develop the bishop and the queen
and get the king away no this is just this is this
is lost uh queen g2 um rook f1 knight takes h2 is
is always on the cards um i mean simple move like
bishop developing and rook over to e8 never
hurts either and as he said danny just he
doesn't have the e3 square so if he plays
like the queen out bishop d2 and castles
there's knight f2 hanging as soon as he does
here waiting for him as soon as he does that
and he's not even going to get that far no indeed
he will not and this is something that i'm sure
both players will look at during the break because
in general in this match it feels like the player
with the black pieces has been doing better and
uh yeah i think the score reflects that as well
i think four wins for black if i'm not mistaken
is that right it it definitely feels that way um
because danny has been doing well sometimes doing
well against that that english he had that one
game where he just crushed um he had one one game
where it didn't work out for him but i think he
came back in that last game and again showed that
um you know he's he's much better prepared or he's
faring a lot better against the english with the
black pieces so i agree it's been a tale for for
both players in this match so far yeah so they are
going to use that break to prepare their openings
but i mean look at this the king on d1 black's not
even down a piece by the way black should be down
like a bishop and a pawn here and he's not and
he's playing c6 of all moves this just ridiculous
oh gosh i mean white could try bishop d2 king c2
can like you run away quickly enough maybe you're
not completely hopeless here well c6 to me is just
not uh not enough conviction in that move i think
knight e3 and maybe getting that bishop out to
g4 with rook e8 um seemed like seemed like that
could uh could definitely work because if white
takes on d5 i mean you just occupy the d-file
and he's regretting it already yeah although i
wonder in terms of the greater match strategy
if continuing to play a position like this can be
demoralizing for danny because you know he me you
know fend it off for a few moves here i think hey
my position doesn't look quite as bad as it did
a couple moves ago it looks really bad but then
you start giving yourself hope and then you lose
the game anyway and you're like oh gosh that was a
painful experience that was as bad as i thought it
was yeah well i think that if he can somehow find
a way to make this game last the distance and not
give another game in the five minute portion and
still win it then lawrence is just a god you know
if he can if he can draw it out and still win it
that's perfect yeah i'm trying to think here in
the three-minute portion who's favorite daniel
lawrence based on what you've seen so far today
it's an interesting question i think probably i
want to say lawrence because danny's time pressure
i think is going to be magnified in that section
um so i feel like uh i feel like lawrence is is
what i would go with yeah he has been playing
much more slowly but it could also be because
when you're used to playing three minute and all
of a sudden you play five minute you you allow
yourself to think more because like oh this is
way more time than i'm used to and that obviously
doesn't help when your opponent's playing quickly
and well yeah this position we still have four
minutes and 40 seconds of this time patrol this is
not going to be our last game unless somehow danny
survives for a few more minutes but it
doesn't look likely no the time i mean
three minute time differential danny is just uh
is the same poker he's drawing dead yeah this is
knight takes h2 can you steal a pawn if you
want it yeah well it comes to f3 as well um
but i think danny would consider that you
know the lesser of two evils at this point
yeah you get king c2 and rook f1 in you just
feel like you are on the verge of escaping so
that's better than you know what it feels
like it could be it still looks bad though
and i see the evaluation bars sinking lower and
lower so black is clearly very happy here yep
yeah the it's more about just deciding what
your method of victory is and knight e3 i think
he's going to take back with the rook um then
followed by like bishop g4 rook doubling on e8
yeah that looks extremely forcing and it was
king c1 maybe the best move because i did not
see a way out after taking on e3 and letting the
rooks double yeah that would have been painful
but here i think knight g2 is just
possible to kick the rook away from e1 and
that 92 is falling after it no this is this is i
think he would have to mute knight g2 with king c2
okay so you're sacrificing the exchange and saying
at least the game continues yeah at least we're
playing at this point okay he goes rook there
but among other things taking on e2 is lights out
because there's not even you don't even have a
threat here uh can't play rookie one and bishop
f5 or bishop g4 the maybe the nastier move is
coming next yeah king b1 actually can be met by
like bishop g4 as you're saying removing the guard
from this bishop on d2 to win a third minor piece
for the cost of just one rook too much
material yep far too much material bishop g4
even knight e3 just trading off more
pieces but i like keeping up the
pressure bishop g4 looks way stronger
as the rook and d1 is under attack
oh man one of these positions where it's painful
for everyone involved it's painful for danny
because he's losing it's painful for us because
we know that the result is not in question and
the game continues and for lawrence it's kind
of like i start you start feeling bad for your
opponent right yeah you're like man this is just
so winning yeah and this will not be the last game
i mean it seems like danny should be losing
in just a few moves now especially after b4
bishop f5 comes to mind sink your
queen into d3 on those light squares
but it's possible that it does become the last
game a minute and 50 seconds so it's getting close
yeah i think we see another one um
just with that 15 seconds rook e8 here
nothing can be challenged knight on g2 is actually
so annoying you loved by rookie one but you can't
because there's a knight there you're yeah this
is this is dunzo yeah it is rook a2 hey that's
a creative defensive move i like that move
yeah i'll give it to him because rookie two
and king a1 happened at least you're holding
on to that bishop on d2 for the time being yep
oof queen takes c3 and mate
at least it's over you know yeah and we will
see one more game in this portion as you can
see the game clock ticking down there's uh
you know little to no chance that somebody
gets mated in less than a minute in this game
and wow we see brand new signs of life here
robert with a new opening to end the portion
yeah what do you think has happened to make
lawrence by d4 he has not been getting good
positions for white so that's probably just
the answer to my own question but now we have a
queen's gambit decline we went from some g4 g5
mess to the ultra solid queen's gamut declined hey
what do you think caused him to play a new open
well maybe it was all those bad positions he was
getting with the white pieces yeah that'll do it
uh i think both people in this match need to
reevaluate their openings with white because
to give them credit they're both playing
tremendously with black and we we need to see more
usually the white pieces are kind of an advantage
and more pronounced than blitz i want to say but
it seems like everything's uh flipped around for
this match so yeah we're ultra solid queen scan
bit uh declined and and danny here's is just gone
for you know classic setup of take that pawn play
b5 and counter attack the center with c5 very very
uh by the book here yeah that pawn triangle is no
more you know the one from hit landing on the d5
square but black gets very quick activity and wait
a second isn't this uh he's dropping there's
some kind of queen c2 that's bound to happen
yeah he's playing dc five well trade the bishops
after rook there play dc5 and take h7 and queen c2
yeah i think this was knight takes e4 is not
the move that you should play for danny yeah
this is yeah danny is realizing that or maybe he's
realizing it right now now he's realizing it yeah
although he hasn't really moved too much yeah this
is this is brutal because you play that end game
and it looks like it will be an end game you're
just down upon this is the worst way to go into
the break he's going to be suffering down a pawn
in an end game where he's most likely to lose
and then he's going to be down two games
going into the three-minute portion where
i would say that lawrence's uh speed right now is
gonna give him the edge and this end game is so
bad that even if you put a pawn back on h6 white
is still much better right because the knight is
better than the bishop in an end game where the
bishop has nothing to attack so yeah this is
not fun not a rook's double the knight has e5
or d4 to go to this is i think objectively just
winning for white bishop wants to go desperately
to be seven but then rook c7 just makes you cry
right so he he does put the rook in d7 first so he
can get bishop to b7 but knight e5 comes to mind
and then rook c7 hit f7 other rook to c1
yeah knight e5 with tempo or if you want to be
very like prevent counter play style knight d4 and
f4 and then just double double the rooks on the
the c file and go to c7 looks looks pretty good
as well that actually made me the most practical
and in fact the smartest choice because 95 there
is rook d2 and then you just start thinking about
things but good things yeah i see i see a knight
e5 rook d2 and hey there might be knight f7s there
might be rook c7s but i look at that and i'm like
you know don't need to give him that much fun
i'm with you and he keeps knight f3 for that
purpose no rook d2 for you the bishop on s8 is
not hanging so you do have one move if you want
to play move like king g7 or something because
if you take on ca twice and this is what you're
showing that there's a rook d1 checkmate well
danny danny's making it a little obvious what
he's up to over there yeah no surprises now you
put the rook on d8 and h4 simple king h2 king g3
you can just maneuver your king along with the
dark squares but do not allow bishop takes f3 so
move that out of the way i'm a big fan of knight
d4 um there's no e5 because the rook is covering
and you just want to get that rook into to
c7 so 95 and 84 both look very strong here
95 i will say it looks a little bit stronger just
because the rook's not on f8 anymore and rook c7
after like a rook d1 trade is going to come with
a lot more poison it's going to hit the bishop
and that pawn on f7 which is hanging at the moment
yeah although i really do like the knight d4 idea
you were talking it's very instructive just to
say i'm going to close down the position put my
net in a dark square you have a light square
bishop and you will have zero counter play
so i can then go win the game however i want so
actually even even if like the better move is 95
you'll catch me playing knight d4 like 10 times
out of 10. yeah i i'm with you there i think it's
just something you don't even need to think about
you know exactly what's happening black is stuck
struggling to find any semblance of counter play
and here well there's no counterplay because of
the very direct tactics as man said the rookstone
f8 which means f7 is even more vulnerable and
i think this is just game over yeah no it's this
is a tough position and danny's gonna have to live
through it uh as as it is going to be the last
game in the temperature so the time is officially
up and i'm sure it has been for a couple minutes
now but that'll be it for the five-minute uh
section and these guys will get a break after
this to to reevaluate some openings but already
lawrence must be looking at d4 and be like wait a
minute why wasn't i playing this the whole match
yes this this turned out well for him but it
was a very bad one move mistake by danny and
it's one of those situations where you release
the tension by trading in the center knight takes
up seven by the way right now is a free pawn
and then the night six comes this is i would
absolutely resign this like don't want any part
of this game maybe you want a longer break you
know you're gonna lose the game regardless so you
spend the next two minutes in your clock and then
just have your full break afterwards if that's
what you need that's smart although i couldn't
sit and stare at this position anymore yeah for
too long yeah um but yeah this is no this is bad
real bad yeah the the if white can orchestrate
pawn to f3 pawn e4 then black is really crying
oh well denny he just you know grabbed his eyes
like i need to see something new i need to play
better chess and he did make a one move very
bad mistake in this game so if this opening
is repeated at least for danny it's easy
to see what went wrong his vision was fine
until he dropped that pawn tactically
whereas in those french positions
i think that that's much more strategic in nature
not just one simple move change you really need
to have a better foundational understanding
of that opening and if danny starts adapting
um and gets good positions with the white pieces
that flips this match around because it really
feels like lawrence is french at the moment is
like a free ticket to a good position and uh that
can change in a heartbeat like danny looks at that
with the engine he starts to collect himself like
you know okay robert's gonna you know
kill me if i lose to the french anymore so
i you know i gotta i gotta improve this and
trust me it's not gonna be hard to find some
lines that lead to an advantage for sure and you
know just quickly go through the game explorer see
what the top players are doing against these
certain lines you say wait a second white has
a pretty good record against this line hey maybe
there's something i could learn from it but now
lawrence trent out to a two-game lead up
five to three aman if you were coaching
these players what would you tell them as we
head into the shorter time controls well uh
tell danny that i'm no longer his coach and uh if
i was being a little more serious i would i would
sit down look at that french opening and really be
like look this is a sideline to an opening that's
already has you know shaky reputation there
are lines out there for you and um you just
need to stop allowing e5 there's no way that
black is allowed to play a french like that
get e5 and just get a good position even the
position that you had in game one robert was was
better than this where he played e5 and maybe he
can reevaluate that one um the positions where the
bishop was getting out to b4 i i like those all
better than what we're seeing so if you're danny
i think you need to collect yourself realize look
you're playing really good chess with the black
pieces and you're not playing badly with the white
pieces but your openings are just not giving you
any chance to play well so really reshape the
the whole structure with the white pieces if
you're in danny's corner i agree with that and
i would say for lawrence despite the fact he has
the lead there are some things that he can work
on as well every game we play there are things
we can take away from it and for lawrence i think
that he doesn't need to force the action so much
especially with the white pieces he was playing
these g4 g5 lines then in this last game he
switched he was the beneficiary of a blunder
by danny dropping a pawn but still i think that
with a match lead you don't need to take as
much risk you can just settle down and lawrence
is playing quite well especially when he is given
an opportunity to uh find a tactical uh option so
with that said ahmad and i are gonna head to break
everybody we will be back shortly with the three
plus one time patrol of this i'm not a gm speeches
championship match brought to you by chess.com
just because this match will end today does
not mean that there's not more chance to be
enjoyed tomorrow as arena kings season six
begins monday january 11th that is tomorrow
5 p.m pacific time so you know you can do the
conversion to wherever you live but it will be a
ton of fun a lot of streamers will be taking part
uh amman the chess bras myself you know you who's
who of the chest stream world will be enjoying the
arena kings but for now oman we are stuck in the
i'm not a gm speed chess championship sphere and
lawrence trent up two games in this match i was
thinking during our short break there that danny
you know he gets the white piece in the next game
i think that he's going to go for it i think
he's going to play something super aggressive
he'll have looked at the french lines but i'm not
sure he needs to worry himself just yet there's
plenty of time left what do you think should
he play for win maybe at all costs right now
or play something a little bit more relaxed and
just let the best chess come down yeah i think
uh danny definitely does not need to overreact
these matches are long for a reason and you can
collect a lot of points in the bullet portion and
we've seen deficits like crazy deficits made up
in just the bullet portion where i think you and
i maybe give that slight nod to to danny as the
uh more comfortable player in that format but
uh lawrence is kind of more of a question mark
in in that regard that we we don't know what to
expect from him there but if you're danny no need
to panic um i think or i hope that he's changed
things up a little bit in the break i'm assuming
he's done so i think that the three-minute portion
is maybe gonna just be a bit more familiar uh to
him robert as you know most players when they
play online they're used to three-minute chess
yeah and i think that's the biggest thing is you
see a deficit scoreboard you start getting in your
own head i'm losing i need to catch up but danny
i would say is the stronger two in bullet time
patrols he definitely has more experience and i
just looked he is the slightly higher rated of the
two in bullets so you know if you can think i just
need to be within one two games to give myself a
chance and bullet don't just rush here don't say
i need to win now and then end up losing the games
you cannot play for results you need to be as
objective as you possibly can be and with the
white pieces starting here in just a second in the
three minute time patrol i think that danny does
not need to just play hyper aggressive chess he
can play his normal stuff yeah and speaking of not
needing to play hyper aggressive that was the
advice that you had for lawrence ironically so
it seems like the advice overall is everyone just
calm down a little bit you know uh both guys have
shown that they they can play some really good
chess and we've seen you know a very crushing game
just on the board from both sides so we know
that it's there and sometimes when you have a
crushing game like that you really start feeling
yourself the next game you just go for something
way too aggressive so don't need to do that keep
it under control now we're back to this french is
danny gonna have something prepared here because
he can't keep walking into these lines and there
we have it bishop b5 which is a way to pin the
knight on c6 it also allows you to take over
the e5 square black if you take on e5 the knight
will end up replacing the pawn once you capture on
c6 first this is what's happening so lauren's
accepting the slightly more passive position
for the time being but says i have the two bishops
maybe down the line i can gain some open space and
use them to my advantage yeah already it doesn't
matter what happens in this game i like the
opening better no matter what so this is already
successful for danny he's got a position here and
i actually don't mind it for lawrence at all
but the bottom line is that this this is already
better for for danny then than what we saw at
least we have a game here yeah it feels like
they're playing on relatively equal footing rather
than lawrence just having the advantage of move
eight and if you look at this position it's closed
down and in a closed position knights tend to be
quite good against bishops look at this bishop on
c6 where's that piece going it's staring into its
own pawn on d5 so black's best move it might be
d5 off the board my bishop one c6 is great right
that's what you want just you take that pawn
straight out of the game and we see f5 g6 like
he's trying to make that bishop as sad as possible
robert he's putting all his pawns on light squares
and he's going for g5 and that's thematic he's a
way to open up the king side because only white's
king is on that flank whereas white would like
to play a4 b4 b5 so we actually may see a very
aggressive game from both players here but i
have a little bit more belief in white's attack
than i do in blacks considering black doesn't
have those pieces developed on the king side
yeah and although you know both sides are going
to be attacking h6 feels very natural but i would
have given a real consideration to knight h6
first getting it to f7 then h6 bishop e7 and
it kind of feels like you're almost playing a
benoni um on the opposite side of the board here
on the king side where you're really trying to get
that g5 break in but your knight on g8 just can't
help that break at all right and well this is
an interesting little move order situation where
danny start with b4 rather than a4 and lawrence
plugged the a4 scope with his bishop so i actually
think dana might regret that decision to
start with b4 even if his position is fine
now i'm looking at the evaluation bar on screen
says about level i think that playing a4 first
made his play much easier to follow up yep
start with a4 and then you can even take
you take it slow with b3 or you can continue b4
b5 now queen h5 which looks like you know makes
the biggest threat in the game is nicely met by
knight g3 hitting the queen and covering each one
totally and another concern i'm having long term
is that if this bishop comes to b5 at the right
moment you don't escape with king f1 king e2 so
king f1 here is not a bishop b5 check and that's a
problem nice nice yeah that's good to keep in mind
that that diagonal will always belong to black yes
and i like the way danny's playing by the way
with g3 king g2 rook h1 trade off the aggressive
pieces because without the rooks on the board you
have no attack so now is the time for just king
g2 rook h1 here i i like that but then i saw
the uh evaluation bar kind of go up a lot so i'm
looking where's the tactic yeah it looked like
maybe just you're gonna take time for a bishop
f6 um and then king g2 might have just been um a
bit better i'm not sure get the rook off the h5
no i think you're completely right that's what it
was because kicking the rooks off the h-file is
a great idea now for example black has rook
h2 check sacrificing material that's why rook
h1 takes care of all those tactics and white
is up a pawn the e6 pawn remains a weakness
and without the rooks where's your attack coming
from oops uh rook h4 uh was coming to mind there
as an idea not sure about that but bishop h4 he's
just looking to plug the uh plug the entire thing
and say look you're not operating on the h file
but i'm not sure i'm a fan of this now no maybe
depending on from the bishops and the fact that
all the play is on the kings side and i see the
the bar it just dipped a lot bishop takes g5
of a rook h2 check this is a big problem the
knight on f3 overloaded defending the bishop
one g5 and covering the h2 square that's that
was a bad move bishop h4 then right back to g5
clearly danny lost the threat so it's gonna be
takes h2 uh takes h2 king f3 and then like queen
queen g8 or queen queen somewhere hit the knight
yeah that looks scary to bring your king out
to f3 but i think your ultimate point is maybe
you're gonna have to sacrifice your queen on
f2 for a rook that lands there and so that's
maybe you bring your knight back to h3 at the
end knight h3 here and then queen how does that
queen attack the knights queen h8 is a potential
move to just put all your forces against that
knight h3 exactly yeah now this is in daddy's
clock his his posture his hand on his head
right now all seem to indicate that he is
unfortunate for him blundered quite a bit
oh this is this is really rough i would even
consider like bishop b5 to like stop the king
from going to e2 oh danny let's go king f4 i
like that move actually because i don't see an
immediate checkmate and yeah okay queen came
to h5 that's a strong move yeah it really is
okay good response rook takes h3 pick up the
two knights for your rook the queen h6 would be
maybe an underrated move here but rick h3 is is
solid queen h6 is so beautiful just painting the
net in g5 so you can steal the knight in h3 for
free oh he goes for it that's a tough move to face
and in the king f3 probably the best move now h3
is always hanging you can get that bishop involved
maybe if you want to bishop b5 looks pretty good
he ends up taking all right that makes sense
okay at least danny's got some moves like
he's he's figured out hey i can shuffle my
king depending on where the queen is that's
good to know right and where's the checkmate
how does this game conclude right how about two
queen h2 queen e1 only move what about bishop f1
that's just disgusting it threatens
queen age once like h1 me the king
can go up to f4 but bishop f1 you can't
take it because in that h2 i think it's
just a good move i think it's the probably
the best move knight h2 mate is the threat
that's dirty that's dirty well wait
white's kind of why it's kind of yeah
like queen h4 okay yeah yeah king
wait now the king's kind of safe
i mean oh danny's getting a in yeah black is
still obviously better but where do you how
do you win this game no this is not that easy i
think you got to bring the king king c6 let's go
oh actually that's great king c6 it's time for
king c6 they're both uh basically they're both
moving a bunch of quick moves they're trying
to gain time on the clock right so queen
whoa what's with queen tiggs yeah that that
looks queen d3 queen d2 coming oh good movie i
like danny's energy here whoa okay oh yeah that's
not gonna help yourself that was not the energy
you were right though he was doing everything
that he needed oh f3 is hanging at the end of this
okay he doesn't take it not for danny yeah
okay yeah this is not going to work out
no this is what you call just bullet
madness and a win for lawrence trent
yeah g4 oh g4 was at least playable
there just uh hope that a mistake is made
but no the pawns are too strong
knight d3 check e2 e1 game over
danny had his chances there that was actually an
insane comeback um it's kind of surprising but
not seeing your bishop f1 like insane kind
of winning move and it actually meant that
maybe it wasn't so winning after
all like you missed that one thing
it didn't look that easy no it certainly didn't
and here we see that we have already in very
offbeat obscure position where the knight is
on d6 and it's even material but the pawns
have been captured the b pawn for the e pawn
i think this is the kind of position danny is
striving for because of the match situation
and i think that for lauren oh gosh oh boy
is it gonna be a mate in the diagonal
not sure danny's striving for this
this is looking sketchy that night on b8
is not a participant and there were a few
moves in a row where danny had like he takes d5
available uh quote-unquote winning that pawn and
he didn't go for it and i mean i'm sure it's
based on a little bit on some theory there but
i'm not sure if that was smart because now you
take it knight takes d5 on top of just the queen
d3 which bishop b1 really gets ready for yeah you
can't play f5 because e6 is hanging i mean just
okay by g6 because the pawn h6 is hanging
this feels not like tilt exactly i think
that danny played this opening to try to
have some winning chances as early as move
two or whatever but yeah this is not going
well that's for sure no it can't be um so
what's the answer after queen d3 um is he
is he kind of like playing no not knight f5
b6 what's he up to yeah what what's that that's
seems kind of irrelevant but maybe it's somehow
right well basically he doesn't want to open the
position up and he's saying like i think queen
c2 queen d3 stuff is good enough on the king side
what's going on on the queen side well i just want
to shut that down the knight on b8 importantly
cannot join the game and it could maybe via a6 had
he reacted differently it's a really good point
so saying the quantity is less important than how
the quality of the pieces are at play here but
now i mean can't black play some kind of bishop e4
seems oh that's a that's a sacrifice for me you're
hitting the rook on a8 and mate on h7 that's just
winning yeah f takes e4 rook takes e4 as a mons
point and that looks that just looks great yup
that looks great queen d5 uh maybe is like a move
but yeah i'm taking on e4 there nice and easy
bishop takes h6 is about to crack the entire game
open oh gosh you know just pick that rook up move
it to some square like rook b4 would be a winning
move to go queen to checkmate the pawn e6 helping
out yeah this is this is game over this is a big
problem danny's down a minute and i want to stress
that the time difference is more meaningful in
a three minute game so if you're down a minute
five minute chest you know that's not the same as
being down a minute in three minute chests and uh
it's probably the worst to be down a minute in one
minute chess agreed yeah i think it does get worse
than that and by the way i've seen international
master teddy coleman the chat who played against
danny last year and he said i was up four games
against danny heading into bullet he actually
caught up so danny's bullet chest does give him
chances but not the way he's currently playing he
is playing to win from move one not with his moves
but with his wishes and that's a big problem what
do you think of queen h7 and bishop g6 followed by
something slow like bishop d2 i love it it looks
just king f6 bishop d2 you play rook e1 and then
bishop c3 and uh bishop h5 there's so many so many
crushes there i would go queen h7 but he's faced
with a free rook in the corner so it's the luxury
of choice that might uh might come back to bite
him here and you have to give credit to lawrence
for spending his time here a lot of us would
say oh it's a free rook oh there's a check on
h7 and make one of those moves but he's trying to
figure out which one is better he does go for mons
check and check queen can't take on g6 and that
e5 check picks up the queen and here comes your
bishop oh should be four g6 is mate oh that's nice
can't fault bishop e4 i mean he wants to pick up
the rook in a better way and leave the guy's
king on f6 i think it's it's all winning here
yeah that's that's pretty nice lauren's figured
everything out and queen f7 queen f5 it's also me
oh gosh yeah this is really painful and if you're
danny you probably want to resign and just get the
next game going okay get the next one started
getting into that territory where you need as
many games as possible and so you're down what
right now white is down in exchange but the rook
on eight can be picked up for free and so white's
gonna be up a full piece with an attack so it's
important i don't have three covers e1 just to
point it out for everybody there's no background
checkmate but with white with such a big advantage
here i think resigning and starting the next game
as soon as possible is the right move totally yep
and there's there's not many moves left that are
good or playable for uh for danny brooke e1 is
going to be lights out the d5 pawn is loose so the
queen has to always watch it each bishop takes h6
is also in the position some sort of combination
of those two moves looks looks decent yeah bishop
takes h6 queen e6 bishop takes d5 check it just
at the very least you win two pawns because you're
already up a piece so you give a piece back for
two pawns and then there's probably checkmate
on top of that yep grab a full piece bishop b7
is also playable let's not forget like that's a
move you know i wouldn't even think about it but
it's probably the best move yeah i wouldn't
be surprised oh gosh yeah that looks really
good queen f5 check should be mentioned as well he
takes on h6 yeah i think he's going for that line
and it says matin too knight g5 and queen
g7 is yeah that's lights out there it is
that's checkmate and that's a four game lead for
lawrence trent yeah and keep in mind this it this
was 3-2 for danny at some point wasn't it and now
it's i feel like it's been four games in a row
yeah we were five in a row is that no it
was three two lawrence it was two to one
danny and then two to one okay that's right it
has been four games in early you're actually
you're completely correct about that so we
have this setup again i like this for white
from the point of view that you have the knights
the position is closed and lawrence is the one
thinking right now and still plenty of time for
each player but he's trying to figure out how
do i properly play this position so that yeah
it's not just closed down oh the g6 square is
i'm eyeing that one but so danny has played
a4 before b4 he's definitely learned that
and that's an immediate adaptation and meanwhile
lawrence is saying look i didn't like the way
that g5 i had to sack a pawn to get the you know h
file open last time so he's going for h6 g5 first
gives up a big square on e5 there and i think
danny should be happy with what what he's got yeah
ecstatic i mean what more could you ask for b5 is
a huge threat because you can't ever open the a
file oh my goodness i mean b5 is the move i would
play if it's a bullet without even thinking but
maybe you do lose the pawn and you could regret
it so not my pieces happy to play b5 and his game
he probably should think about it before doing
it yeah i would maybe insert like a rookie one
um first just to get on that e file it feels like
that's where you're going to want to be no matter
what um whereas the e4 square you're always taking
care playing f3 so kind of makes me stay away from
moves like f4 being a little bit too aggressive
there on the king side i think it's uh you know
ideas like b5 uh takes takes bishop a3 um kind
of what he wants to go for and yeah he started
with rookie one just a slow approach yeah and
i'm reading chat and i see a comment there
lawrence he's doing the dumbbell
thing again yeah he's got the
he's getting a quick workout in did he watch
the the last match between alexandra and greg
shahadi where alexandra started the match with
some workout weights and do you see the movement
but h5 giving him the g5 on for free yeah i
think that he should do more of the flexing
over the board and less so uh with the weights
because he just dropped the big pawn for free
yeah it seems like maybe the blood left his
head went over the biceps for a moment there
h5 is on the board and i'm not sure danny's gonna
be too concerned seeing that i think this is a one
of the one of the games where danny just i think
has a massive edge and needs to win this game for
the match situation for sure he's winning he won a
pawn now he's winning in exchange because once the
knight moves the rook on d8 will be captured and
there's still some chances for lawrence because
of the opening of the king side not too many
white pieces on that flank but objectively the
position is overwhelmingly strong for danny just
take that rook on d8 next yeah and knight e4 is
even worse because it will result in um well after
we exchange everything a trade of queens which you
can't allow so yeah what he's done here makes
a bit more sense knight g4 more aggressive move
but i mean takes d8 h3 to kick the knight out it's
always there h5 pawn hanging h3 what a good move
and danny plays it saying that night even if it's
not doing anything just yet there could be some
potential for it especially if the queen landed
on d8 so the queen go to h4 next let me first kick
that knight out and then figure out if i actually
want to take the exchange and now take on d8 just
give me that rook and doesn't that win even
more things than before and now he's gonna
have a full rook i don't know if that's enough
material but it does look very strong i think
lawrence was trying to rely on some kind of knight
takes f2 and opening the g-file and things like
that but it feels i thought maybe h4 by lawrence
was like the trickier kind of in-between move to
play and he has gone for this but he wants d4 and
hitting the g2 pawn but this is something you can
just sit back and tell yourself okay this doesn't
work you can just start with that tell yourself
that and then find out why bishop takes h4 seems
like a good starting point you're up a rook and a
piece at this point and queen g4 also has to be a
good move because if you can trade the queens off
even if you lose both the knight first and g3 than
the bishop one date you still have a rook for a
bishop and several extra pawns important to note
rook f8 is bishop f6 otherwise that would be a
big catastrophe so yeah danny worked through this
and figured out his bishop f6 very important move
queen f3 here keep offering the queen exchange
don't let lawrence keep those on the board even if
he does keeping the board white is doing well but
i would try to play queen f3 here and definitely
everything's coming off everything's coming off
queen c2 check there's rook e2 yep and he's gonna
have to trade that and yeah he got an outside
pass pawn here i think it's pretty reliable
he's gonna put that rook on d4 and the other
rook maybe to each one and just push push push
push him baby where's the officer when you
need him just h4 h5 and there it goes yep and
you know lauren says he's picking up that pawn
he's going to try to cement that bishop on f5
it's not going to be good enough but it is it is
a good try i mean florence was basically down a
rook at some point and hey he's got this position
in a three-minute game it's pretty reasonable but
i think if danny plays this one right uh correctly
he'll be he'll be fine yeah and it's one of these
positions where you can give up your pawn e5 if
you play f4 you give up some of these important
light squares that could be tricky but as long
as you can kick this rook off of h5 and play h5
yourself so rook g4 here i don't care for my e5
pawn i just want to sprint that pawn with the
board danny does so and yeah love that move
um if the rook takes an e5 as you mentioned
h5 h6 and the rook on e5 blocked by its own e
pun it's just really hard to get back in defense
exactly and so lauren's also down on time rook g5
now just bring your rook out step by step by step
although you can't get the g6 don't blend to that
yeah i think what if you ever have a chance
you want to sack your rook for that bishop
as well like bishop f5 you snap that off the
board and bring your king in yeah he's just
no king of 14 g5 the good old-fashioned oh
with the other direction nope not sure why
oh look there's rook f7 rook f6 that's annoying
yeah that's annoying so a382 and rook takes a
h5 like the h pawn in general and danny
gives up that pawn disagree big disagree
yeah this is still very good for white but much
harder to convert absolutely so rook a7 there's
king b6 king b6 and bishop kind of goes to f5
this is not the conversion that you need here
can you no don't take yet but you can at some
point consider taking that bishop one f5 yeah
king d2 and rook b4 rook f4 good move oh no
that should be three check oh my goodness oh
and danny is very frustrated here as he should
be yeah danny danny might lose this game
very very possible yeah that was a good move
though because c5 pushing those pawns yes take
that and f4 danny you you're really at risk
of losing here wait you could win now again
because well he's supposed to win he's up
on time and it's uh takes d4 takes uh oh
rook f4 takes and you queen with check but white
white has the extra pawn okay so that was sneaky
from lawrence though yeah and if queen c2 is
queen e4 check so that's why i went king here
extreme queen c5 okay repeat now king g4 okay no
checks nicely done no checks is the worst feeling
okay now goes the pawn but there might be oh
quindy finds queen e5 check so you couldn't
check uh from over there queen h3 is the nasty
check though yeah gotta go f6 queen h4 i mean h6
queen h6 was the draw or this is good too yeah
wow yeah i think danny had to get his queen
back close to that pawn um just spend a move bring
it back and often those queen end games are the
ones that you usually win um are we do we have a
break or we do the players get a mid time control
break so they can refresh themselves danny will
have the black pieces when we resume but for now
lawrence trent enjoys himself a four game lead
and amman that game just there that has to just
crush your spirits if you're danny because you
had to win in the bag a million times over yeah
you you have the the h-pawn pushing you're up a
rook at one point up a piece in exchange you name
it uh danny had it in that game and that was the
first time that we've seen him prosecute a good
opening into an advantage into what should have
been a win and if lawrence is getting away with
even those plus he's winning some games himself i
don't think danny has a road to a comeback unless
he can turn some of these games around and at
least get back on the board for his confidence
and we will see when we return just a
few minutes for more action from the
i'm now gm speechless championship
brought to you by chess.com
and we are back ready for the second half of this
three plus one second increment time patrol among
we know that lawrence is out to a big lead danny
has played some impressive chess along the way
but the results not matching his level of play
i'd say yeah no uh i i think this match has been
a little more psychological like lauren
says felt like he's had the upper hand
in most time scrambles felt like he's just been up
on time in general on the clock and as i mentioned
i think that becomes more pronounced and we've
seen that in the three-minute section lawrence
trent has really run away with the match a
little bit in this format so in the second
half of this this format here after the break
danny is really going to have to uh come back
just collect himself and get a few points on the
board because i think if this trend keeps up with
the points lawrence's scoring even if danny makes
a comeback in the bullet it's gonna be very hard
to make up this kind of distance i agree and you
know in game seven when danny lost that one then
he had one final game the five-minute time patrol
he lost that as well we blew under the pawn uh on
h7 with check and the c5 square so it seems that
things have just been getting out of control for
him and now with the black pieces he needs to stop
that spiral and right now he brings his knight to
e4 this is a common idea that if you can play f5
you feel pretty decent about your position however
i think knight fd2 instead of rook to e1 was a
good move there yeah but i was going to point
out something interesting that happened that was
just a product of the players not being stopped
was that uh lawrence played this opening and got
to see that danny was going to play the queen's
indian and then the game was aborted and then
they took a break so it's just kind of weird
danny hadn't played that before lauren's probably
went in the break like yeah i might take a look at
a few lines in the queen's indian all of a sudden
yeah you know it does give him a little bit of
insight into his opponent's repertoire here but i
like black's position i tend to in these openings
because you look at these double c pawns and
they're stuck in place you don't even need to
play c5 which sometimes is a good move to then try
to open the c file look at this queen c8 it gives
you more flexibility the queen could come directly
to a6 or you could play c5 and just that c4 square
it feels very vulnerable here yeah i mean queen
a6 and sometimes even trading the c7 pawn for
the c4 pawn could be in black's favor just to get
that end game bring the rook to the to the c file
and not deal with any tactics and maybe that's
the type of game that danny wants and he really
can't excel in i'm with you there because you know
in theory you're like i don't give a pawn c7 for
double pawn and c4 but there's that backwards
pawn on c3 that always has to have an eye kept
out on it so he said he plays bishop f6 which
makes it move like knight e5 a little bit less
welcome and maybe c5 comes in where there are more
tactics available and h4 by lawrence just playing
on the king side here what's the point yeah well
i think after queen a6 he's generally looking to
immediate with knight d2 um to keep that under
control and in the meantime after knight d2 or
regardless of that move i think he was looking at
the move uh maybe d5 and maybe e4 just to kind of
break things open say look you've got a knight and
a queen that are really offside on the queen side
i'm looking to play on the king side with e4 d5
maybe h5 at some point h6 and say that look your
pieces are on the wrong side of the board to help
defend yeah that actually makes perfect sense so
that's why danny i guess brought queen in from c8
to c6 wait what isn't c4 pawn just i mean rook b4
was really called calling to be played it
danny did something a little tricky by the
way he played queen b7 and then queen c6 and
lawrence was probably like knight d tubes
just it wasn't working for him because it was
pinned so that that was sneaky by danny but i
think lawrence did have rook before to to cover
things or there was maybe bishop e7 what a weird
position he probably had that but it looks very
awkward and that's why lawrence quickly went
king h2 and rook g1 and objectively black's
position is great here but we've seen in the
past lawrence getting himself in a tactical
position where he has come out on top and
if he can make g4 work and open up the g file
bring the second rook over there you could see
the black king getting in some danger but for
now with that knight coming into e4 for example
it feels like black should be very happy here yep
g4 and this was expected whether it's good or not
it was expected um i think you could give uh
consideration to queen e4 if you're you're trying
to try to get the queens off the board knowing
that the end games are going to be good for you
yeah e4 looks like a great move too hello queenie
for it it's the practical choice just like let's
trade these pieces off although here queen takes
c3 i guess you can accomplish that while stealing
another pawn oh but d7s hanging more things to
calculate yeah things just a bunch of things
uh i guess queen e6 is it's also possible trying
to play d6 saying look f2 is hanging but at the
same time white wants to play f3 kick that night
out and and then continue from there yeah and h4
is hanging but are you in time to capture that
your move f3 looks very strong here just to kick
the knight out but knight d6 can be played as a
simple response and what's the follow how does
white take advantage of the fact that you kicked
piece in the last couple moves and can you take
on h4 i want to take that pawn but i'm somewhat
worried that i'm opening the position up even more
and i know i'm up a second pawn but opening
files yeah you have to deal with the move c5
as well after bishop takes h4 just as like kind
of a hit on on your piece there and then maybe
d5 follows up hits your queen i think lawrence is
doing the right thing which is hey your position
is already a little questionable why don't you
dare your opponent to take another pawn which
usually people don't want to do they're
like ah that feels a little too greedy so
um he's sort of maybe leaving it
there a little bit like a bluff but
i like what danny's doing he's more controlled
don't worry about that pawn trade pieces yeah it's
great choice knight takes f7 rook f7 bishop
takes c7 looks like a hanging pawn but then
you play d6 and the bishop gets trapped on c7 so
there are tactics still available in this position
c6 yeah c6 looks strong just kicking the rook
right away from defense of the night now yeah
that's just material i think he wanted some knight
f7 trickery you know and brook takes f5 but after
knight f7 you can take that rook on b5 you can
and you will that's just scooping up material
and looks great for danny so he's playing a really
nice game after what must have been just this like
hurtful game where he didn't win right
before the break now he took on f7
curse i'm sorry i i i'm so sorry that's how
does that happen take the rook there's no
threats for a night on f7 um so you don't
trust yourself that's that's what happens
oh this is heartbreaking yeah because you can't
take yeah i was gonna say you can't take on
d6 even the bishops just lost g5 may as
well chuck that in there yeah just nope g5
okay wow on to the next game for danny it's
like even when he plays these great games
at the start he's not playing them start to finish
he's playing them start to like two moves before
the finish every time and that's not enough it
really feels like he doesn't trust himself and
the game before the break was different because
he was just winning heading towards the end game
that game there were still complications to be
figured out and he didn't take the rook on b5
because he probably oh the knight will give me
a check or there's something against my king
whereas if you gave danny even you know uh freshly
that position on new day he'll just crude and
what is this a5 i mean this has to be horrible
for black even b4 here looks very reasonable
and danny danny is probably at the point where
he's like listen at this point i don't care if
i trust myself it's time for b4 i'm down in the
match we have to turn this around somehow and
i think maybe that was the kick he needed he's
like this is not acceptable just b4 let's go
and i like his position right here this looks
horrible for black because yeah you're up a
pawn but you're down several moves in terms of
development it's so easy for white's play rook
rook to be one yeah which files we want to operate
we can play rook c1 we play rook b1 and then our
knight to e1 knight to d3 for example oh yeah he's
just pushing a5 there's there's uh okay knight h6
he wants knight f7 g5 um but i i just think
that's too slow you just don't care right you
grab all your pieces and you just throw them on
the queen side wherever they'll go but how do you
actually end this game like that's the annoying
thing is of course white's attack looks strong
and he just puts his not enough force there's
no attack for you i've hurt your pawn structure
you can go knight d3 or knight both are
good to take those dark squares even so
is it time for something as slow as like knight
d2 move the queen knight b3 knight c5 like knight
on c5 feels like you're closing in on the end of
the game but you do you do move everything away
from the the king at that point yeah i think he's
thinking about it though i think that's his point
right 92 he does it yeah it's definitely his
plan i don't think it's the right one but it
is what he's going for yeah if you double the
rooks and the g file at the end of it white
plays g3 and says okay what'd you accomplish here
yeah that's a good move i imagine because of 1983
you can play like bishop c4 do you want to even
just take take the knight and say look if you
play a6 i got b6 and knight c5 i'll take it at
all times i'm somewhat concerned that you know
once you give up the bishop then the knight moves
away and the b7 pawn becomes a very big target but
maybe you are right that you have to do
this and just hope that it works out just
it feels not great whoa okay knight c5 and i would
use the knight that's not attacked or sorry the
knight date is attacked it's an idea i see e3 to
c5 yeah looks reasonable and yeah trading queens
doesn't feel good when you're down a pawn but even
there white has a good position because e6 pawn is
the weakest pawn but he does play his knight
is it gonna is it gonna be bishop uh c4 here
knight takes beasts i don't know if it works but
i'm trying to make the attack work yeah knight b7
it's a rook g6 yeah that's i mean good
question hey what's next for white over there
i don't know g6 is nice because it guards e6
nice little multi-purpose move there yeah you
can double the rooks you protect the pawns your
queen is free a6 played b6 uh b6 immediately
so where does your queen is bc5 a threat
because knight a5 could be a response so like
perhaps you can give up this knight
on c5 but right the bc knight a5
is is interested there is queen b6 after that so
i'm not fully convinced but um it's definitely
something to keep in mind otherwise if you're
just trading queens here then a6 is horrible
and you can't even trade queens right because
knight a4 takes a4 and knight e4 just take that so
yeah what's the play here an
extra minute for lawrence as well
maybe like rook c1 and then if you take on a
c5 then you go knight a5 and you have uh like
dc at the end maybe we just start with
knight a5 he played rook c1 so he's going
for this kind of line here but yeah this is
very sketchy i think he's going knight a5
i don't trust it no i don't trust that even queen
e8 can i just run away that knight v7 at least
it's tricky right it's tricky queen a5 it's c4
c4 and that's it yeah no more attack for you
no c4 hurts here and look at the time
he's just gonna resign he's just like
had enough of that had enough with
the way that he's playing and i think
i think danny's at the point where it's not that
he doesn't trust himself anymore he's just like
he he's he's not having anything go his way even
when it looks like the position is so dominating i
feel like he kind of stopped calculating that game
at some point and he was just like yeah let's you
know intuition let's just throw these pieces and
then all of a sudden you can't throw them anymore
ran out of them yeah the thing that lawrence
is doing best of all is playing very quickly so
even when he gets into some shaky territory he's
able to use the clock to his advantage and danny
hasn't been able to figure this out throughout
the day and here is another example that's just
pawnee four and after ponzi for maybe just even
take it again with your knight or play e3 it's
not a position that looks particularly
good for black e3 or bishop e3
he's got bishop f4 and he's opened up a six point
lead now and i think g5 i mean i don't know how
much he's calculated g5 but it looked like he
was almost ready to play bishop c7 knight d5 take
f6 and fe yeah looked worthwhile for sure and
that's why neither player you know gets to
see that happen knight e7 play that's a good
move knight g6 to go and get that bishop
on f4 and that would make e3 and other squares
more vulnerable so i actually think that danny's
position is good here and he's moving quickly so
that's the big end in the position he is moving
very quickly so he should be able to continue
improving his position i don't mind c6 it
kind of looks bad at first sight but bishop
c8 bishop f5 or even just the e6 queen d7
the knight on c3 is the piece that needs improving
if that knight was on f3 there'd be an e5 square
waiting but knight on c3 is not a great piece here
and e4 is looking to try to remedy that yeah and
he's giving up a pawn because the pawn takes e4
the d4 pawn is under attack with check but what
lawrence wants to do is get that knight to d6
and just starting to create some very concrete
issues for danny's minor pieces so he does take
with the queen on d4 i think that lawrence will
not trade yeah maybe king h1 yeah i like
that because you can then win the bishop pair
and that could be a problem whereas if you take
on d4 oh okay so it goes bishop e3 instead he
wants the bishop on d6 or sorry on f6 followed by
like a queen d7 and really really getting in there
yeah though the fact that his rook's no longer
c1 is a problem because with the rook on c1
you'd have 96 ideas but now isn't black just up
a pawn yeah that wasn't the best by lawrence but
i don't think you're too concerned here if
you're playing white because that blockade
is fantastic on d4 yeah and if rooks come
off the board it's immediately going to be a
drawn position so yeah i think white can just
play king f2 next and troubling rookie one
and not that he did this intentionally but match
strategy there's seven and a half minutes ticking
down here uh i'm not sure this is the best for
danny because he's gonna play this a while and he
has a good chance to not win it yeah so i i can't
really force a draw right there's no way for danny
just oh you must make this draw otherwise
you lose no i mean lawrence can just kind of
maneuver around for a while yep yeah that's
not good although if you play this long enough
and lauren starts getting time travel
that's how danny could win this game
yeah no there's definitely a chance danny wins
it but it's almost like danny's gonna win this
game it's gonna take so long that you start even
wondering if it's worth it but but yeah i think i
think danny should play this on hey he's up upon
this is his this is a chance absolutely although
i like what lawrence just did because he's
gonna play rook d4 and he does so if the rooks
are traded no winning chances for immediate draw
and oh danny is admitting it's a it's a draw but
lawrence doesn't have to take the draw right away
no lauren should be smart but king e3 then played
bishop h8 bishop g7 bishop c3 just used that
bishop on a yo-yo string on the diagonal and
waste time and that's exactly what he's doing
and if i'm danny i'm not making moves like a5
i don't want a new position i want the
same position i want to make that draw
yeah this is not this is not what you want danny
offered to draw and he took it wow look at that
would you have taken that draw given
the fact that you're up six points here
i feel like it's the considerate thing to do from
a broader games you know gameship point of view
but i think that you know why would you because
you can waste time like for your own benefit i
don't know it's one of these situations i
always find tricky because i i would think
that i wouldn't want to do that but if it helps
me win the match which is what my goal is then
i don't know it's you've done nothing wrong by
playing on okay this is speaking of doing things
wrong this opening has to stop from lawrence yeah
the problem is he's winning the games so what you
know like it he's gonna have to take a beating
for it to just okay now now it's gotta stop
this this this one danny you got it buddy i
mean put him away this is this is too much here
too much just b5 queen b3 pawn c4 just throw all
your pieces forward it doesn't rush it and this is
not good at all for black nope f3 looks maybe
unnecessary but i understand it like didn't want
to see pawn f3 on the board but looked unnecessary
and gives away some squares for no reason
agreed so queen queen b3 looks very logical here
yes yeah queen v3 or a b5 in some order what is
black aiming for in this position i think i think
he's just playing like knight f5 bishop e7 h5 g4
like he's just kind of doing that i don't think
that he believes in his position but hey it's
solid and there's if there's no breakthrough on
the queen side he's just he's just hanging out
yeah you're right it actually has a field where
h5 g4 rook g4 even though the f4 pawn drops at
least you can look at that reaction h3 it's just
not like you don't need you don't need that move
yeah it typically helps black because then you're
opening up more lines when you get g4 yeah like if
g4 happens in that pawns on h2 the most that can
happen is the g file opens up and now after g4 the
g file could open up by taking on h3 and if you
take first that's two files open up no matter what
yeah so how does danny actually increase his
attack here because rook c14 with c4 as an
idea he plays a6 trying to just open up the b file
but can you take and run your king to d7 and just
run away i think that's what he's going to do i
don't think he likes b6 because a5 gets played
um he would play b6 maybe if there was no other or
second a pawn but here he just takes it says look
knight c5 i'm always capturing meanwhile i
got g4 coming and i don't really care about
any of the puns and queen b8 check king
d7 there's nothing special about that
it just looks like it should be good for white
but here comes black attack and yeah you played
h3 you're opening up more lines exactly what we
were talking about here rook takes g4 the h file
is open the g file is going to be pressure on the
g2 square though that knight on f4 that's really a
heroic piece because it defends the pawn and also
at some point the e6 pawn could feel quite loose
yeah i'm trying to trying to think what do i do
next as white that's the that's the issue that i'm
having yeah knight takes g2 is suddenly a threat
because they're you just kind of sacrifice a bunch
of ps in the queen g6 at the end the knight md3 is
loose the king is out in the open so i would not
want to allow that that's for sure yeah knight
g2 take everything queen g6 and all of a sudden
we have this position where like all of danny's
pieces are on the queen side there's nothing
going on over there and you can play queen f7
or you can take on g2 as i think knight g2 is
the the way to go bishop h6 is where you kind of
forget that you need that guy to stop knight c5 so
don't be doing that you know actually you said
bishop h6 wait that actually looks good and you
said you finished your sentence of wait you need
to cover the c5 square yeah very good call and
that's exactly how the brain would work too it's
like okay bishop h6 looks normal but lawrence
he seems to be finding everything he needs to find
this might not be the best engine move but i love
it yeah it looks very good to me and i don't
even see a way for white to fend this position
off because your king's out in the f file in
the open there's a rook on g4 there's a queen
coming into the game here rook takes g2 i yeah
this is exactly what's on queen g6 takes d3 and
now that you've taken the knight on d3 now you
can move that dark square bishop and you should
because that rook from d8 wants to go to f8 g8
or h2 i'm not even sure which square it's going
to it depends on where the king goes but king
h1 there's bishop b4 for example just look at
this king there's nothing within like a 4x4 box
of it like this is ridiculous so so exposed here
um danny's king's just gonna get hunted down by
the pieces and don't forget please down a minute
on the clock as well this is just all going wrong
for danny in in this match as it's becoming more
and more clear that lawrence is just playing
fast comfortable he might not be getting the
best positions but the they're ones where danny
is not able to prosecute the advantage yeah i
mean look at this kingdom on the open you should
probably play king e1 king d1 king c1 and just
run your king to where you have pieces but it's a
position where it's actually even except for the
fact that white has a rook and black has a bishop
but the rooks are not actually helpful right now
you have the open b file that's great yeah but
it's not leaving the checkmate on the other side
the king on f2 here's bishop h4 check ffa check
yeah this is over he wants bishop there and queen
f3 but brook or sorry bishop h4 first followed by
the rook getting involved is going to lead to me
somewhere oh that'll do it and we have time for
one more game it looks like there's 10 seconds
left yep so this will be officially the last
game in the uh the three minute time control and
at this point it's like if if danny loses another
game it's not only the demoralizing feeling of
going into a break on the loss but just that
the lead is going to be so insurmountable it's
going to be eight points at that point and
that just feels like too much and finally we
have seen this knight fd2 move i mean we saw
it once before but taking advantage of the
fact that bishop on b7 is not defended yeah this
position opening up black's king in the center
now hang on a sec this is different than last time
yeah bishop h3 probably could have played there
well it's just that wasn't he castled last time
how did he like steal a move there oh yeah how
did he what's this oh did the rook go to e1 i
think for lauren so instead of playing rook e1
he immediately played knight f3 to d2 right which
is yeah there we go that was it that's much better
um okay that makes sense i'm taking this bishop on
f4 if i'm danny i'm down seven points i'm taking
on f4 and asking questions later yeah that's very
reasonable just go follow up with bishop d6 knight
d7 because now i think he could even play bishop
e5 f4 just kind of chuck that bishop into e5
brook takes out four if it's their
next move is definitely a consideration
yeah okay still there if it's there
one more turn it's a consideration
now's the time right no oh okay he's not
doing it but now the bishop comes to e5
just like you were saying and that's a pain
yeah both bishops look good here for white uh
this is solid just solid for uh for lawrence here
comes f4 yeah not even necessary at the moment but
right exactly what i said you don't even need it
yet in the rook c2 rookie that's a pretty classy
uh rook lift by lawrence just a double works in
the e file so he sees that that's where he wants i
like bishop c8 yeah bishop c8 looks reasonable and
then you trade and play rookie too i guess yeah
no this is this is comfortable for
for lawrence like eval might be
equal-ish but um let's be fair this this is easy
to play for white i love the rook c2 rook e2 idea
danny's uh giving up on trying to remove that
bishop he says all right that's that's yours
yeah and now the e file bishop c7 i was about to
ask you is there some bishop c7 you just wouldn't
exchange oof okay he dropped it back and white
is still doing great you have control of the only
fully open file the bishop on f4 better than the
counterpart in f8 the bishop on b7 way worse than
bishop one h3 queen e6 check there's like queen
e6 queen f7 can i just bring my pieces in and
yeah all the time there's no the queensland bishop
c bishop c7 oh my goodness bishop c7 oh he's just
walked into it oh gosh yeah oh so laurence has
missed his fair share of wins in this game so far
yeah and he's still winning well you know you
have the active pieces here it's a queen on
f7 or rook on e6 and you just look at the
pieces one by one probably the only about
equal pieces of the knight on f6 and the knight in
c3 otherwise all of white's pieces are dominating
yep someone in the chess.com game chat just
said that lawrence is on danny like a cheap suit
oh gosh night g8 oh man danny's really setting up
the board here for uh for the one minute portion
this is not a good look there's gonna be some
puzzle rush win here somewhere yeah it's like
is there going to be some h4h5h6 then
is it that is it knight e2 knight
i like knight e2 knight f4 and then you know
there's gonna be some dirty stuff there that
actually looks great can you stop that 92 and a
4 queen each five minutes i don't think so knight
f4 is gonna be like there's not a single move
that makes a threat rook's trapped queen's more
or less trapped c5 knight f4 and lawrence knows
there's going to be just a ko here yeah c takes
d4 you're rook finally doing something on the
open line but as you're talking about knight g6
or even just knight h5 going for the g7 pawn that
should do the trick queen g5 i can get behind that
so the knight can move with his queen c one
checking all that stuff oh okay trading rooks
i see the and then queen e7 maybe yeah and even if
you lose the d5 pawn at some point it's worth it
but i was just looking at the yeah the bar and
it went down quite a lot there i don't know why
maybe bishop e7 that looks reasonable
even pontig's d4 i guess is playable here
just to uh yeah the bishop one e5 is not
defended very well yeah that's i think that's
a good move that must be that must be the vibe
because then you go bishop c5 if he takes back
right that's definitely it yep danny locates that
one and will we see lawrence getting punished for
not putting this game away bishop c5 go go go yeah
because otherwise bishop 96 when the g7 pawn would
have been a disaster so bishop c5 says okay we're
forcing the bishops off the board then this d-pawn
can try to become a pass pawn uh then i like
it white should have an easy time making sure
that pawn's blockaded that's a i don't know how
danny turned that around it's pretty impressive
yeah it looks just completely lost and now
it's like wait there's still life absolutely
so even taking a knight f6 is you know one way to
go probably not the best but hey hey everything's
defended and when you get closer to an end game
you especially when the queens are on you stop
viewing the d-pawn like an isolated pawn you start
viewing it as a pass pawn completely agree and
look at that move good move by lawrence try and
trade queen so the king could then go to the d4
square blockade the pawn of course your king can't
go and block hit upon when they're queen's on the
board it's too dangerous i like the way lawrence
is playing this now though yeah he's really doing
doing this well how do you even stop g5 i think
you gotta go like for other you know queen
i don't know what the move would be
you gotta get some counter play going
queen c6 or so he goes queen d6 probably
some knight e4 idea 94 now okay 97 yeah
four seconds and like it's safe to say
that danny shouldn't be winning this game
no so he's just trying to survive so b3
knight c1 typical plan to win back upon so
oh he's gonna have to check back it's
just b3 knight c1 that's the idea
how do you deal with that actually yeah you
might have to just go for the kingside pawns
so flaming like f5 check or something and try
to yeah see what he does because if king e5 i
think king to h5 and g6 is too quick so he has
to go back so i like starting with f5 that's a
really good point because it looks like you're
putting the pawn on loose squares but as you're
suggesting the white king was run in and look
at this i think he says look i'm i'm up in the
you know i don't mind a draw going into the
next portion keep my lead no point in like
playing f5 maybe and then going on to lose somehow
to some outside eight pawns so i let's just say i
i understand from a gamesmanship perspective
what lawrence was up to there yeah he's just
maintaining the lead the worst thing you
can do is lose that game whether it's a six
point gap and danny can try to win all his bullet
games but it is seven points lawrence trent out to
a huge lead we will have bullet remaining is there
any chance for danny what do you think can he
win seven games in a row in bullet is there even
time for that well yeah i think the first question
is is there a chance for danny mathematically
that's i think where you have to start because
um if there is a chance for danny mathematically
then you start about how credible it would be
for that to actually happen and in the bullet i
think if i was you know having a match go this
way the number one thing i'd want to do is
go play bullet so this might be the you know
the only chance for danny but um honestly uh i
i don't think so uh the way the match is going
i gotta give full credit to lawrence trent for
the way he's played so far he's played quick
he's played controlled so unless we see just like
some sort of horrendous version of lawrence trent
in bullet i think he's got this match robert
yeah i have to agree and i would say that
just to reiterate what you're saying that even
in the positions that were objectively bad for
lawrence it wasn't a clear knockout for danny
he started burning clock and lawrence started
playing great defense to survive so it's
going to be uphill task doesn't come close
to covering what it will have to be for dan
to win this but we will take a quick break
and when we return we'll come back for the bullet
segment of this i'm not gm speeches championship
and as we return for the conclusion of this
i am not gm speech has championship match
should we want to give a shout out to dr wolf who
provides very friendly personal coaching for those
who are have ios download it for free it's a
great tool to help you improve on your chest
personalized coaching is generally
speaking a very beneficial thing so
definitely get on that use dr wolf and oman
i think that danny needs to turn into a wolf
right now because he needs to win every single
game and there's not even room for a single draw
no that's the way it feels right now i might have
to get danny on the dr wolf app as well for some
quick time pep talk but uh it is uh drawing dead
uh for he's drawing dead he needs to win as you
said every game it feels like if he draws loses
maybe it's mathematically possible but he's gonna
have to be like meeting trent in like 20 moves in
some games so uh if if we get these long drawn out
games opposite bishops stuff like that it's not
going to favor danny who needs to be cognizant
of the clock um as we mentioned it's not about
whether danny can win seven games it's whether
seven games are actually going to fit into this
time control which is as you said only 25 minutes
yeah one single 75 move game and all of a sudden
you're might be out of time so danny goes to d4
i was thinking he might do this but he's done it a
bit too late considering uh you know the score but
he got good positions against the french it wasn't
really the first move that did him in and here
we have a london system and i mean the sad part is
his position is already better okay by the way i
love this position um is this just already better
than like everything that i've seen this match
yeah it's easy to play for white and now look at
him going super aggressive on the king side i'm
not sure it's justified just yet black can just
park a pony on e4 and say where's your attack
coming from but yeah yeah wow um i don't mind
b5 from from lawrence uh my concern for danny is
that the knight on e4 just like can't be removed
it's so annoying um oh takes the knight g5 yeah
i saw the eval bar go crazy too just knight
takes f7 just still still still again again again
although what he's doing is he seems perfectly
good for white right now he's just saying please
take me on g5 i'll take with the f pawn i'm
going to crash through on the king side anyway so
oh f6 just take on e6 like you don't care yeah
i felt like that's what danny was gonna do um
where was this type of conviction in the other
formats yeah he has just planted his knight on e6
and what's happening capturing e4 f5 as possible
but i think he wanted knight c5 but he's hanging
and just and not people not realize there's a
night hang in there yeah that knight could have
been captured and should have been captured
because nobody runs away queen b5 though and
c or b3 okay maybe a bit more solid of an approach
but i like what lawrence is doing he's trying to
strike on the queen side and what does white do
now rook h to e1 that has to be the move right
whoa oh not a fan not a fan of that move ah
but force force galore and after knight c
there's knight b6 coming yeah take it it's
like they don't realize pieces are hanging
take that guy on c8 they're just so important
yeah they're no still hanging what's queen a7 now
like he's getting mated yeah that turned pretty
quick queen b2 only moves and then rook c6 rook
a6 oh gosh that's painful okay they're not
focusing all their attention to the king side
they play on one side of the board only it's
like all right we're going to the queen side
lords a couple moves here back to the other
side oh didn't like that knight takes c8 nope
what yeah this is gonna be a
problem with a knight lands there
the knight is more valuable than a rook
so i would not be taking the roof on d1
i would have played d5 there oh wait seven
yeah say the same thing rook's coming to e7
i would have taken the rook on b2 because
he's gonna take b2 with check no he's not
what is happening here knight e5 just i can't even
do it he doesn't though rook takes b2 a check and
wait what's happening knight
is on e5 he's gonna meet him
is white winning this oh it's winning
yes take it and then you're saying
what just happened oh my gosh what was
that guys we need to see this danny
in every game from now on just every game this
danny needs to show up seriously what was that
and danny learned his lesson by the way
because he didn't put his night on e4
until um either lauren food is rook or castle he
looked at this yeah yes he clearly did and this is
and he played d5 rather than f5 so some changes
in danny's approach f5 now makes sense just to
protect the pawn on e4 and yeah i still can't
get over that checkmate on f7 that's hilarious
that is hilarious because he could have gone
to f8 as well right like he chose to go in
the corner and then it just presented itself and
this position for danny can't can't complain no
certainly not if you need a win i mean at least
the c4 pawn's under attack the bishop one f6
looks good even if white objectively is doing well
here take out your c3 maybe take c3 queen e8 type
of stuff yeah i love that love that oh actually
can you just take and take on d5 you just win
the pawn directly i think you could take on d5
and rook d1 then maybe queen e8 yeah and so now
he's having pawn has the c4 square for his knight
but i like that d4 square for lawrence's bishop
yeah now there's no queen eight no queen
d7 i think you almost got to go like
f4 or queen g5 yeah that makes sense he takes
in c5 but that's just gonna be recaptured and
all right he's trying to trade off pieces
he is up a pawn so that's understandable
now that looks like a strong move to me that
looks like a very annoying move to face so 95
i looked at the uh you know our live screen here
and the evaluation bar went down so that meant 95
is probably winning yeah because the queen can't
move from d8 so it would have to be a move like 95
but it wasn't played that this looks very good for
for white i would say and maybe e4 bishop takes g7
for q7 yeah that's the tactic didn't see it's a
knight d6 maybe six probably is the movie but c5
also looks reasonable and can't play rook b8
that's the problem the knight oh that's annoying
oh i like this though oh hang on i don't like
this though it can't go to c it's close though
i liked this though okay so going
after f3 so d4 oh d4 it was also gonna
bishop uh chills on d4s really nicely yeah and the
a7 pawns undertake g7 now h7 can be captured yeah
nice nice it's could be a mating net yep king to
h5 oh rook a8 oh he could take on b6 and take on
c3 as well you know he could have uh captured
that but rook 8 is more principled i would say
so king no don't make a draw i think he's going
to yeah because king g6 rook jack king wait a
minute why didn't he do that he could have run
his teammate file yeah what yeah that would have
been better for sure the the miscalculation that
i had in my head was like oh king h5 rook takes h7
but that would never be possible yeah
and all right danny going back to his d4
opening and has expanded the center lauren's
trying to undermine white center with pieces right
now hitting it on f3 if the knight moves from f6
the d4 pawn is going to be under attack so knight
can go f6 to d7 was a possibility and said he goes
like this and well i'm on it seems like white has
a very nice position at the opening yeah i would
say so i think i think that uh lawrence is not
going to be unhappy like sometimes you take these
positions in bullet with black and they're just
so quick and easy to play that's true so you
give up sort of the objective value in terms
of like purely neutralizing the position for ease
of play and that way you can conserve your time
definitely that's a big big dislike on that move
yeah because now it's gonna be good night against
questionable bishop queen h4 queen f4 yeah keep
keep the queens for sure but look at that knight
on e5 just can't kick that one out h4 time
for h4 yeah he does it h5 h6 queen of six
uh lawrence closing out closing everything
yeah do you want you want to play a5 the queen
comes to c5 so i'm going to take over the c file
yeah up to you i want to play queen f6 and like
well if you do it now you actually drop the g
pawn funny enough good to note that the queen
on b6 pins that pawn so it goes king g2 can you
get g4 to happen that's what white desperately
needs to wow and lawrence is doing the pragmatic
thing i think he's going to go like a5 kng7
queen f6 which is so annoying to play against
and i think that white's objectively lost even
objectively lost and objectively going to play
like a three-minute game here yeah and so i think
danny needs to somehow come up with an attack but
there's none to speak of none rook on e1 at least
get the at least get the rook operating and look
at this he could have taken b3 he just puts his
rook on queen at c7 keeping everything closed
bishop c2 okay gotta be bishop c2 yeah here comes
queen c5 knight g4 is now a threat no no brutal oh
if you didn't see knight g4 he's gonna find it
now yeah and there's almost queen e4 and c2 but
too fancy too fancy night age two checkups oh
that might be the the dagger in this match with
16 minutes left you got to feel that that danny
needed that after a draw and a loss consecutive
that that's just not enough and danny's opening
here is hot garbage as they say well it looks like
a french that lawrence was playing throughout the
match and yeah this is really bad even queen
h5 taking over this king side can't recommend
no steer clear um so there's gonna be
a sacrifice in e6 potentially available
does it work i think so takes queen e7 take
knight d5 bishop g5 looks looked crushing yeah
but okay lawrence is not looking to take risks i
think at this point but i like black's position
now because if you can just chisel that white
center you're probably just losing a pawn as white
yeah he's very losing a pawn but these often
backfire you just chuck things like f4 next
after g5 the bishop one g7 not being protected is
huge you're right g5 f4 and can't take it without
losing material because white just you know chucks
that bishop out of the way rookie won and it's so
easy to play this and bullet with white a big fan
of what lawrence is doing he just didn't care one
bit about that on e5 yeah you kind of trick your
opponent in a way because taking on d4 take on
e5 looked very nice winning material but actually
the pressure and the build up was good for black
so probably taking on d4 was a big mistake
in einstein just bishop i don't know e2 or d3
knight c5 makes sense to me oh he's gonna take it
and he might even go queen yeah i was gonna say
queen c7 queen d6 stops castling makes a lot of
sense okay so queen e7 mate is a threat bishop oh
wait good move i think i would take on c6 and just
and long castle yeah maybe okay queen g7 is very
pragmatic though okay so black's up a pawn right
yes black is up one pawn here he's got the bishop
pair i mean definitely a fantastic position he's
solved everything from the opening he's got
19 seconds but i mean a bullet i think he's
still got a lot of time relatively speaking
e5 winning a piece no it was knight h5 okay
so that was a little tactic that lawrence yeah he
would go in there anyway but somehow this doesn't
feel very easy for black people what's danny's
knight doing on b7 by the way it's hanging out
he really put it there on purpose i don't
know what it's doing too yeah i got nothing
but now it's there there it is a very useful
square so e3 yeah b3 to take away the c4 square
that makes perfect sense instead lawrence is going
on the h file trying to win this h6 bomb yep okay
that knight has taken a journey by the way and a
pretty successful one knight e5 b3 for white b3
b3 looks completely reasonable 93
okay the g2 point is underneath
four oh this oh no that's that's bad this is
a catastrophe the 93 is actually trapped so
and the knight on d4 is so strong yeah this
is this is gg that's a shame right there
your knight is trapped on e3 still even after
all these trays that's insane by the way yes
knight c6 all winning the knight was able to
trade himself off but even still what black
takes f7 fancy that would be a great way to
take advantage of a pre-move right because
expecting night of seven supreme bishop takes that
would have been really cool there's richie one
there but yeah i feel like the pre-move is worth
an attempt i think so in terms of expected value
from that position i'm with you poor danny this
is this is going to be a loss because those rook
end games are the worst to play as well yeah
because they take forever right you not only
are you losing but yeah yeah there's a resolution
danny's yeah gonna throw in the towel on that one
and we actually see the ratings evening
out in in bullet so whatever they started
with they're pretty much identical now and
here we finally at long last have a scotch
and is is d take c6 bishop d3 some pre-move
stuff because is danny getting mated here
queen h4 knight takes h2 i mean i just queen
g3 whoa queen g3 is winning on the spot yep
hmm do you think yeah maybe he went d takes c6
hoping for some kind of pre-move because dc6
you just trade the queens feels like you have just
like a way better berlin or something yeah so this
is is it danny's turn for the attack knight e4 etc
etc yeah here it comes careful of bishop h3 but i
think queen f3 will be played yeah queen of three
looks good and then f5 is coming there's queen
oh because the queen one check yeah queen e1 it's
good move by danny there yes that f6 check we'll
pick up the bishop on f5 for the night but black
can just start capturing so not too scary yeah
this is a clean exchange up for black yeah still
bishop d3 you can kind of plug the d file a bit
yeah but now that the position is opening up even
more the rooks have the d file the e5 and now
yikes yeah this is not going to cut it here
for uh mr wrench no it certainly will not
and it's one of these situations i'm on
where there are 10 minutes left in the
match and you're just like i don't want to play
anymore yeah i've lost right bishop coming to d6
okay rook some d7 of counterplay bishop d6 as
you said rookie one checkmate coming right next
g3 g5 oh yep a piece that's a piece and
lawrence is higher rated in bullet and
honestly what i thought was going
to be one of the closest matches
is extremely not one of the closest matches
it could be one of the biggest blowouts
yeah just one of those days right
where if you started this match
tomorrow and just said okay clean slate it would
very likely be much closer or it could even be a
blood and danny's favor so it's credit to lawrence
for sure he's played a really energetic and strong
match i i have been really surprised pleasantly
so about his defensive tenacity like there were
those positions where he uh ended up casting
queen side and was in danger but he was able
to stave off the attack while creating attacks
of his own so the the way he was able to obtain
counter play throughout this entire match has been
really awesome to see yeah and that's just uh he
has to be a good defender i think with his style
when you play that the sort of intuitive quick uh
moves quick style of chess you have to be a pretty
good defender because you will miss things from
time to time playing as quick as he is oh queen c6
won the house there yeah dude this wins oh i don't
even know if you want to take that pawn p2 because
d6 f6 would check so you might have to take this
knight on e4 but then the queen centralizes so
yeah queen takes c6 missed opportunity there
okay checking a5 seems weird
king f1 or c3 even he wants c6
queen d5 choose trey taking on d4 king d2
and isn't white kind of up a pawn because
black's pawn is doubled on h file and white's
pawn is a potential passer on the b file yep
the virtue six was nice right because you just say
if you're ever going to trade me you're undoubling
my pawns on that side of the board yeah i don't
think he'll bite on that rook a3 by white though
it looks like a great option oh yeah actually gate
three looked almost winning it probably was right
there was really nice just full board awareness
by man saying the rook on g3 yeah it's great i'm
fighting for an open final rook to b3 for instance
g3 to b3 or now rook g through to a3 that could
just now he sees it now he sees it there it is and
two connected pass bonds over there is going to be
two connected pass bonds too many yeah you're not
even winning a pawn back for black that's oh no
now the king maybe goes and helps out these pawns
yeah king f3 king g4 also comes to mind if you
want to steal the spawn h4 yeah he needs to play
rook h1 danny he's not actually catch one right
now which one danny there you go take it you know
oh and now d4 is in trouble wait
how many pawns do you just give up
yeah he i still think white wins this but um we'll
see h2 oh okay rook ooh hang on f4 f4 i need f4
okay good move yeah now you're too slow and
the rook's gobbling all the pawns up take on h7
it's tragic yeah even when every game he was
coming back just didn't work that story of
most people's chest crew oh it looked good
and then it didn't work yeah no it's true
and here we have these pawns on b5 and a6
and it's actually a reasonable opening at
this stage it looks not so bad for black but
you're giving up central control for some kind
of pressure with your queen side pawns but yeah
that's just maybe four ideas six minutes plus
even if it's a win for danny in this game
far too little and far too late definitely
definitely too little too late here and we've
been talking about how oh knight d4 uh nice
i was good as i was about to compliment uh
lawrence's uh you know tactics and defensive
skills there he finds another one taking advantage
of the king and queen being on the same diagonal
and he's tried this but i feel like when white
stops that h3 thread that if you okay take and see
that's really smart because yeah i didn't like the
look of that knight getting to e4 at some point
rook takes c3 with rook takes h3
ideas oh gosh this might happen
you take twice on b5 and rook takes h3 mate
oh man he sees it now he sees it now
yeah maybe queen ooh queen c6 still hoping
for bishops he wants it he wants it bad
can white try f5 maybe and you know go
for an attack on zone okay bishop e4
oh oh look at that queen f2 that was true oh no
but the meat is oh it's not me not me because the
queen blocks the diagonal maybe takes and rook g3
next oh that's just yeah it doesn't you're a a mon
it's a draw yeah yeah it's a draw but you get
to make the other guy suffer it's like oh you
got a queen and a rook who cares buddy yep and
brooke oh and rook f2 by the way was the only draw
that's actually crazy because i thought
you could move your work anywhere but then
white plays rook f3 to give up the rook to give
the sp space of the king along the first rank
a cheeky draw yeah for and b3 now here come
the b-pawn movements i caught a little uh a
little danny smirk half chuckle at the uh
at the draw there so you know he's he sort
of admitted to himself that we've hit the end of
the line here the the match is going to go to to
lawrence although it may have been mathematically
clear a while ago it feels like it just became
evident to these to these guys yep and look at
this queen d5 wins on the spot for black right
well there's a there's one for
danny robert yeah we got one
you know it does probably feel a little bit better
to get a couple wins down the stretch because it
seems like there will be time for at least one
more game after this one maybe two and if you can
cut into the gap you feel at least like okay i
didn't lose by 12 points i lost by seven it's
not really much in terms of consolation
but all right you'll take it
yeah you don't want to be the biggest blowout of
the event so he's trying to give other people a
chance to earn that title indeed and okay well
knight at five queen e4 check go for the maid
yup knight f5 is a good way to start just
stopping queen e3 as a resource to block
okay king the king's run to c1 survive yep
he lives queen e1 might be the only room
still down a piece so you know even though
you're not checkmating should be sufficient
here oh god knight d4 yeah the knight into e2
i like that oh brutal position queen c1 just a5
yeah time for a5 where's the checkmates i'm
kind of sack on b3 coming right now take it
yeah you crashed through nice
that's well that's maiden yeah okay you can sack
the queen true and now it's an extra queen so i
don't think we really need to come to too much
on uh the current position hopefully we don't
yeah five extra pawns and a queen for rook that's
i think uh danny can handle this one yep no more
tricks up lawrence's sleeve and this one here
and that leaves us time for just one more game
after it yeah most likely one more game um
shouldn't be more some free moves there
yeah and well cutting the deficit to nine
lawrence
and that'll that'll be a win for danny there let's
see if he can get his 2600 back and higher rated i
was gonna say that right if he wins this game he
ends up with a higher bullet rating yeah that's
that's about as much of a win as danny can take
from this match right here yeah there's definitely
some hang and stuff like take and take on h8 at
this point i don't think either guy knows or cares
what they're doing now moving the pieces around
trying to have a good laugh yeah and oh this looks
terrible for black knight h5 queen takes d5 that
knight is coming to f5 or h5 i'm not sure which is
better but both will be available bishop takes
a g5 just castle yeah bring the knight to d6
knight e4 with tempo okay or f5 same idea
agreed
maybe danny can get a nice puzzle rush mate
in here somewhere it feels like it's close
well that's a free very free piece
and we might get another game
oh my gosh one more queen eight
check and then queen takes f7 yeah
i think he wants the match to end yeah
don't blame him no not even a little bit
13 12 11. it's the countdown yeah danny did
he wants another game is he going to get it
five seconds i think he he's looking at the
clock he's like i don't want any more no i i oh
this one doesn't count right i don't think so
f3 no no okay the kings are coming out boys
yeah these kings are coming out i
guess there are lines to continue
and well well the worst part is if
lawrence wins then he's higher rated today
you know it's not that bad for white right now
it's looking pretty good paul's coming to g4 and
then i guess the g3 is some attack for white on
the king side it's the bong clap yeah now it looks
pretty bad again there's there's no more fitting
way to finish uh robert this match than this
opening right here how did we get from what should
have been a tactical position to some kind of like
strategic one now yeah now it's like two bishops
versus the you know the double pawns and whatever
oh that was good yeah bishop h4 check coming okay
de2 and bishop h4 just please please even if you
go go d2 and just take the queen back it also
looks good right damn doesn't look so bad either
oh it's miss chances this is not the vibe no
no this is hey a good little in-between move
there with rook a to b i like that bishop
back to c3 bishop c5 coming for black
okay bishop i think bishop c5 would
have stolen the b2 pawn with check
yeah king e3 rook d2 bishop b4 here
bishop before this b4 is really nice
yeah now it's like king e3 and he's got this
little formation although he has to watch g6
knight d6 takes takes rookie eight yep so nice
to retreat somewhere to maybe g3 and then bishop
i'm still looking at bishop c5 i feel like
trading the bishops is going to be good for
black the pawn on d3 is somehow untouchable yeah
it's this weird weird position we got here rook c2
okay so knight h1 to f2 like the only oh i don't
like the knight there it doesn't really help you
so what now bishop e7 yep just bishop
d8 bishop a5 oh that looks good too
there's some bishop e1 stuff as
well yeah that's some weirdness
okay so now you can get d4 in that should help
somehow i don't really know exactly how it helps
but rook d4 is all knight f5 rook f4 knight d5
oh oh oh oh no it's tragic it's tragic for danny
yeah now that knight's just jumping
everywhere lawrence basically has a
position where the knight jumps are all he
needs for sure knight d8 or knight e8 to d6
too many night jumps oh there's another pack here
there's no good discover check that was like you
know perfectly take the knight take enough six you
have chance there oh that's maybe seven oh that's
very meaty yeah can't even go rook g1 because the
bishop covers that e5 doesn't even do anything
it protects the g7 square except for the fact that
knight's already there well that's that come on
we uh see the match finally come to a close and
lawrence trent wins it by the score of 17 and a
half eight and a half and nine point spread what
a match it was by lawrence yeah we really got to
take uh a moment and give the the full credit to
lawrence here um we could we could say that you
know some of it's on danny for missing his chances
but i feel like lawrence came in with a game plan
um he started out really well or she said at the
very beginning he maybe was a little sluggish but
he really found his rhythm and he found the ways
that he could take points off danny whether it
was using the clock getting up on time taking him
into positions where objectively might have the
worst evaluation but he knows the ideas uh well
enough to play it in blitz so i thought he came
in with the game plan he executed it um but you
have to put a little bit of that uh blame onto
danny for missing his chances and most importantly
when things were looking tough and he got his one
chance he didn't even convert it yep i concur
and we are going to go to a break and when we
return we will have both players for the post
match interview so lawrence and danny will
join me and amman so stay tuned everybody
we will be right back with the post match
interviews
and we return with both players danny our
apologies the matching go to your way and
lawrence a big congratulations because you know
you were off to a bit of a tough start at the
first break you were down two to one what did you
change what did you tell yourself that allowed you
to go on a really big winning streak after that
um nothing particularly i i was quite happy with
how the french went and i thought i'd keep on
doing that obviously my english experiment uh
was exactly that it was an experiment so when
i switched that up i got a bit more stability
with white but i just thought as long as
danny isn't punishing me when he has white
then i'm you know i'm i'm gonna have a very good
chance in the match and yeah i i think we both
played pretty badly actually today to realist
i think in general the level was quite poor um
i just managed to you know convert more positions
swindle in a couple of spots as well which always
makes quite the difference and um yeah i i i guess
i probably deserved the match overall but it was i
think the score flatters my uh my my level of play
i i don't think the margin was as wide as that so
obviously you know commiserations to my boy danny
um yeah i don't know what what else to say i think
you're giving yourself enough credit i mean you
picked this french line which you said just now
off the before we were with these guys that you
specifically prepared it for the match and i
had no idea what to do against it and and then i
looked at the line briefly at the break and even
though i objectively knew like white was getting
good positions like from a practical perspective
you made a very good choice and the fact that
you like completely punished me with the french
will go down and and the list and the list of the
greatest the greatest embarrassments of my life um
and so um you you were the better player today you
prepared you prepared and made it made a very good
choice and so don't don't don't sell yourself
too short man i think you played really well
thank you no i i mean yeah i just uh i don't even
know how i came across this line as many people
know follow me i'm not a french player at all um
trying to find something and you played this you
know this scotch and everything yeah i don't know
i wasn't even going to play the scotch by the way
i really could yeah okay i was i was gonna place
it but it didn't matter i mean i i i admit that i
i did not put the level of preparation you did
with an opening choice like that which just
i mean i feel like you you won the match
right there on a practical level because
even though i started off on the right foot i
yeah i couldn't i couldn't figure this out and
even when i was getting good positions i wasn't
comfortable i was i was constant or time pressure
it was frustrating honestly and then about
midway through the three minute i just like
i was just i was just really really down with
how i was playing so but you uh you kept your
foot on the gas and then i was then i was toast
well yeah i i guess i just managed to convert
and yeah the yeah i think as you said danny you
should have probably switched it up yeah yeah
and then i think it would have been a bit more
competitive but yeah because in the end danny you
actually ended up trying just about every white
opening in the book and yeah you had some e4 games
some d4 games and it seemed like once you started
switching it up the positions got a little better
but you were stubborn with uh with trying to beat
down the french and i think that was something
that you uh you didn't want to give up is that
right like you felt like you had to beat the
french rather than then avoid it 100 i'm nothing
if i'm not a man of faulty principles and so i
when he was playing the french i was like robert's
never going to let me hear the end of this crap
i was like i got it for you i said on air i was
like screw robert sitting there telling me that
i can't beat the french and damn it he was right
so you know that's what was going on in my head
yeah we figured and i mean lawrence on your end
right you took a lead at four to three and you had
just enough time left for a final game in that
five minute portion and then danny end up hanging
upon with this bishop takes h7 check tactic but
i'm just curious what made you switch your opening
in that game was the fact that you took a
lead and wanted to play something more solid
or what was going through your mind i was playing
this nonsense g4 english that some norwegian guy
tried a couple of times um you know basically
never trust that guy uh yeah yeah the whack and
uh yeah i and then i was he he played this bishop
take he didn't take on d2 and i was like god i
haven't prepared that what an idiot and i was
just getting really whack positions which suited
danny's style and he was just beating me and i
just thought you know what i'm stubborn enough
with my stock market positions i think it's time
to switch it up and you know cut the losers as
they say cut the losers quick let the winners
so we had to give that garbage up and then we'd
switch to something which i also looked at uh this
uh queen's indian and which is solid and you know
you get decent positions which actually don't
think suit danny particularly um so i think that
was probably the best decision i made in the match
was just been in that daft english very very well
yeah well it was it was tough it was tough for
me i got to be honest it was uh yeah and it's one
of those things where like i guess i i shouldn't
expect much better like i mean i'm not it's like
one of those things where you hold yourself to
a standard of what you think you're capable of
and then all of a sudden you get over the head
with hey you're not as good as you think you are
and matches like this just like humiliate you so
it was it was frustrating i mean i felt and then i
and then i felt like i couldn't gather myself like
mentally when it started to get away from me like
that's just the honest truth like i couldn't and
and like you said i think i just should i should
have gone away from the french earlier and and
probably it's a different match then but yeah
you know you get all the credit man i mean
that was like and i also think even in the
time scrambles you were just better i mean
like i i was i was nervous and i was getting
under time pressure and i couldn't i couldn't
quite find it today so i mean i you know that's
kind of my thing i know i'm answering questions
before robert and amanda answered asked me but i
just just sitting here in my head like why did i
why did i suck so bad today like that's the only
question like robert and aman should legitimately
be asking me like why did you suck so bad today
and i can't figure it out other than i give
you credit that you really threw me off my game
so that's kind of the honest truth well you
may have lacked some highlights uh today danny
but you had one good one you had one smothered
mate knight f7 mate in an absolutely insane game
i nearly fell off my chair there because as soon
as you as soon as you allowed rook g7 king h8 and
i played 96 like i perked up in my chair i was
like i don't see how he's winning it right away
so and maybe there was even a mate for you
on the board like there probably was like
i'll be honest with you i didn't even see knight
f7 was yeah i just thought you were making moves
yeah do i take the queen what do i do no i just
i didn't even see the mate and i nearly fell off
my chair luckily already uh i had such a margin
that's the sort of game by the way where if greg
shahadi is watching oh gosh you know that's
the sort of game that greg would win against
me he'd swindle me but there would be like a two
point gap and then i would go on monkey tilt and
i would just blast off the next few games
and he would win so that's how greg does
it but i just got lucky shout out to greg if
you're watching buddy i just got lucky that
um i had such a big lead in points today yeah
well lawrence as someone who has you know
unfortunately or i can say i i empathize when
people make fun of you like not beating magnus up
a rook and things like that like today i wear the
face of shame and failure and today you are the
victor so i'm just glad to be like you know just
the the guy that just i feel like i i really hit
the bottom of the barrel today so you know we all
have our bad days i mean derek henry run 40 yards
today so i mean what's he paid millions for if
he can run during this broadcast you tell me yeah
well you know i feel like i feel like the next
time you and i throw down we're definitely gonna
have to have banter you know because oh yeah then
at the very least if i'm getting my ass kicked
which i think i can say i'm a player today so i
have to worry about it um then the very least i
can get some good one-liners in there so that's
true i i'm up for that and uh yeah yeah just
yeah obviously happy to to win a match
it's been a long time since i've won
didn't you get out of the first round last year in
this event oh maybe i won the uh yeah definitely
did you die yeah you won yeah i think i won the
first and then i played john bartholomew in the
second oh yeah yeah so um yeah well thanks for
making our life very easy because the mom and i
yeah we didn't really prepare questions you but
you answered all the questions we should have
asked so what you're doing you're dealing with
chess commentators you know lawrence and i are
our chess commentators not just players but
uh that's correct i just like i said i said
the only question you can legitimately ask me is
like danny why'd you suck so bad and lawrence like
you know what was your what was your approach and
he obviously kind of explained it and he crushed
it so you know um anyway man i don't have much
else to say unless you guys have more questions
well it's very entertaining danny unfortunately
at your expense uh this match but it it was a
enjoyable match and i know it definitely wasn't
much fun to sit there and take uh take a bunch
of l's today but uh we we had a good time
commentating and i think the people had a good
time watching so take solace in that cool congrats
lawrence lauren seriously man good luck man
thank you i i don't know who i'm playing
next but uh yeah i don't know either
on that side of the bracket you'll
play the winner of alina kalashninskaya
i feel like you can you'd be the favorite in
your next match i don't want to jinx it man
but i feel good about your channel
managed to jinx it quite well but
last year last year i lost the teddy and he
made it to the semis this year he's going
against the the monster known
as karissa yep so oh yeah he's
important uh well that's it yeah
all right nothing more for you guys
exactly go enjoy your american football
all right guys thanks very much all right see you
too yeah see you guys thanks again for for a great
match congrats again laurence all right well we
see that lawrence moves on he faces the winner
of roberto molina and alessia santoramo and for
danny well his run has come to an end even before
he could get into a gate here so well we look
across the bracket amman this one's done but
we have another match in just a few days from now
any i don't know what to say they feel like they
said it all yeah like that's a great thing about
having danny on the broadcast he just handles the
interview questions and interview answers and
i feel like that was the easiest post-game
interview i've ever had to do but yeah we do have
the next match coming up which i guess is levy and
james canty which we've mentioned earlier but
now that is the the next thing to sort of preview
but uh but yeah this is for most people um
pretty one-sided match so we'll basically see if
if levy can do what his rating says he should do
on paper yeah these kind of matches not always so
clear-cut when you lose a game you get frustrated
as danny was talking about today he just
could never find his grasp of this match and for
lawrence trent he did a great job of course in
his ability to play an opening that danny wasn't
expecting and that didn't really feel like he had
a good understanding in and as you said come on
we started the show with this that stubbornness
was causing the players some very big difficulties
yeah no i feel i almost feel bad calling it as
accurately as i did because i don't like to see
the matches wind up like that but that did feel
like kind of the story today robert but uh yeah
a very decisive victory for for lawrence against
danny and what we thought was going to be very
close match coming into it danny couldn't find
his rhythm and lawrence was punishing game after
game after game so a big congrats to lawrence
trent on victory and he'll be moving on in the
bracket i am not a gm tournament for sure and
i want to thank everybody who's been tuning in
for all these hours of course we want to thank
the players and the production crew who's really
made this such a great show aman i want to thank
you it's been a while since we've commented
together and i'm definitely looking forward
to more coverage of this event with you yeah no
i'll be i'll be back for uh as many of these uh
matches in this event as i can so definitely see
some more of me it's been a while and a pleasure
commentating today with you robert for sure
and to everybody thank you again enjoy the rest
of your sundays and tune back in for more
chess content brought to you by chess.com